This episode is brought to you by Square. You're not just running a restaurant, you're building something big. And Square's there for all of it. Giving your customers more ways to order, whether that's in-person with Square kiosk or online. Instant access to your sales, plus the funding you need to go even bigger. And real-time insights so you know what's working, what's not, and what's next. Because when you're doing big things, your tools should to.
本集由 Square 赞助播出。你不仅仅是在经营一家餐厅，而是在缔造伟业，Square 将全程为你保驾护航。无论是通过 Square 自助点餐机进行店内点餐，还是线上点餐，都能为你的顾客提供更多点餐方式。你可以即时查看销售额，还能获得助你迈向更大成功的资金支持。更有实时数据洞察，让你清楚了解哪些方法行之有效，哪些需要改进，以及接下来的发展方向。因为当你志在宏图时，你的工具也当如此。
Visit square.ca to get started. Where's your playlist taking you? Down the highway, to the mountains, or just into daydream mode while you're stuck in traffic. With over 4,000 hotels worldwide, Best Western is there to help you make the most of your getaway. Wherever that is, because the only thing better than a great playlist
访问 square.ca 即可开始使用。你的播放列表将带你驶向何方？是驰骋高速公路、奔赴群山，还是在交通拥堵时陷入白日梦模式？Best Western（贝斯特韦斯特）在全球拥有 4,000 多家酒店，随时准备助你尽情享受假期。无论目的地是哪里，因为世上唯有一事胜过美妙的播放列表——
is a great trip. Life's the trip. Make the most of it at Best Western. Book direct and save at bestwestern.com. We have some fun merch news. Yes. We are back with a limited time pop-up merch store. Yes, and we have brand new Office Ladies merch for you. It is available September 3rd through September 17th.
那就是一场绝佳的旅行。生活就是一场旅行。在 Best Western 尽情享受每一刻。直接预订，尽享优惠，请访问 bestwestern.com。我们有一些有趣的周边新闻。没错。我们带着限时快闪周边商店回归了。是的，我们为你准备了全新的《办公室》女士（Office Ladies）周边。贩售时间为 9 月 3 日至 9 月 17 日。
We've got some classic designs that we know you love, plus an all-new Scranton Hot collection. We also have a super cute Finer Things Club tote and a water bottle that says Office Ladies, sassy since 2019. So if you've been waiting for new Office Ladies merch for yourself, your best friend, your sister, your mom, your hubby, now's your chance. Head to shopofficeladies.com and get your order in today. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends.
我们既有大家喜爱的经典设计，还有全新的“斯克兰顿辣妹”系列。我们还准备了一款超可爱的“精致生活俱乐部”托特包，以及一个印有“Office Ladies，自 2019 年起风情万种”字样的水杯。所以，如果你一直在等待全新的《办公室》女士周边来犒劳自己、挚友、姐妹、妈妈或老公，现在就是好机会。前往 shopofficeladies.com，今天就下单吧。我是珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer），我是安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）。我们曾一同出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。
And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive. exclusive interviews, behind-the-scenes details, and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello, there's everyone. Holy moly, do we have a big episode today? We are going back to the Office universe. We sure are.
而现在，我们为你带来了终极的《办公室》爱好者的播客节目。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节以及大量闺蜜故事，带你更深入地探索《办公室》的世界。我们是 6.0 版本的“办公室女士”。大家好，各位好。天呐，我们今天有一集重磅节目吗？我们将重返《办公室》的宇宙。我们当然会。
With the paper. The paper. You guys, the first four episodes are out now on Peacock. Check them out. Today we're going to talk about the pilot. And we got some behind-the-scenes scoop for you. Behind the scenes, lady. We had exclusive access to the set.
带着那部报纸剧。那部报纸剧。各位，前四集现在已经在 Peacock 上线了。快去看看吧。今天我们要聊聊试播集。我们有一些独家幕后内幕要分享给大家。幕后花絮，女士。我们拥有片场的独家访问权限。
We got to talk to the actors. We got to talk to the crew, the writers, the producers. And for those of you have been following along with us, these past four Fridays, we have been releasing some of those interviews with the cast members, some of the people we were able to talk to during our visit. So definitely check those out if you missed them. Well, we've got a lot to discuss. I think we just got to get into it.
我们采访了演员。我们采访了剧组工作人员、编剧、制片人。对于那些在过去四周一直关注我们的朋友们，我们在周五发布了其中一些与演员的采访，也就是我们在探班期间采访到的一些人。所以如果你错过了，一定要去听听看。好了，我们有太多内容要讨论了。我想我们得直接切入正题了。
Let's get into it. Today, we are talking about the paper. This episode is titled Pilot. It was written by Greg Daniels and Michael Komen, Michael Komen, Ellie Kemper's husband. This was directed by Greg Daniels, and this episode is 33 minutes and 18 seconds. Well, here's the thing. Right away something new from the offices, they get to have more time. I know.
让我们切入正题。今天，我们要聊的是那部报纸剧。本集的标题是《试播集》（Pilot）。由格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）和迈克尔·科门（Michael Komen，也就是艾丽·坎伯的丈夫）共同编剧。本集由格雷格·丹尼尔斯执导，时长为 33 分钟 18 秒。好了，重点来了。办公室剧集带来的一个全新变化是，他们有了更多的时间。我知道。
And how much fun is that? I mean, as I was watching the episode, I was so wishing we could have had this extra 10 minutes per episode because, oh, my gosh, you see what that gives you. And I guess thankfully now, Dave Rogers is giving us all of that in the superfan episodes. True. Well, here is your summary, folks. The documentary crew that filmed the office is now looking for a new subject. And they find it in a historic, struggling Midwestern newspaper called The True. Ruth Teller in Toledo, Ohio. The show focuses on the paper's newly hired publisher, Ned,
这有多有趣啊？我是说，当我观看这集的时候，我多么希望每集都能多出这额外的 10 分钟啊，因为，天呐，你看这能带来多少内容。我想谢天谢地，现在戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers）正在“超级粉丝版”剧集中把这些统统呈现给我们。确实。好吧，各位，以下是剧情梗概：当年拍摄《办公室》的那支纪录片团队现在正在寻找一个新的拍摄对象。他们在一个历史悠久、经营困难的中西部报社——《真实信使报》（The True Teller）中找到了目标，报社位于俄亥俄州托莱多。该剧聚焦于报社新聘用的出版商内德（Ned），
whose goal is to revive the paper using volunteer reporters. All right, we're going to do fast facts, and Angela, you're going to kick us off. Yeah. All right, fast fact number one. So like we said, we got to interview some of the cast, and we also got to talk to Greg Daniels and Michael Coleman. We asked them if they could share with us about the premise of the paper. Here's what Greg had to say. I do want to preface this with, if you guys haven't listened to the interviews, Jenna and I showed up with only one microphone. And our batteries died on the microphone when it was finally time to talk to Greg and Michael.
他的目标是通过招募志愿者记者来重振这家报纸。好了，我们要进入“速览快讯”环节了，安吉拉，由你来开个头。好的。好吧，速览快讯第一条。正如我们所说，我们采访了部分演员，还和格雷格·丹尼尔斯以及迈克尔·科门进行了交流。我们问他们能否跟我们分享一下《真实信使报》这个故事的设想。格雷格是这么说的。我得先说明一下，如果你们还没听过那些采访的话，当时我和珍娜出场时只带了一个麦克风。而当终于轮到采访格雷格和迈克尔时，我们麦克风的电池居然没电了。
So we had to plug it in. And then the only way to be close to them is if you and I sat on a conference room table. We have a picture of this, of you and I sitting on a conference room table. Leaning towards them with this one microphone. So if you hear a little clunkiness, It's because we're on a table. Well, the premise of the show is that there is a company that bought Dunder Mifflin. They basically own anything that produces or uses paper.
所以我们不得不把它插上电。唯一的办法就是你和我必须坐在会议室的桌子上，才能离他们近一点。我们有一张照片记录了这一幕，就是你和我坐在会议室的桌子上。拿着这仅有的一个麦克风，身体向他们倾斜。所以如果你听到声音听起来有点怪怪的，那是因为我们坐在桌子上。好吧，这部剧的设定是有一家公司收购了邓德·米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）。基本上，任何生产或使用纸张的公司都在他们的掌控之中。
So they have Dunder Mifflin, which is office supplies. But their biggest product is toilet tissues and toilet seat protectors. And then they also have a few newspapers. because they also use paper, but the newspapers are the least money makers and they're low man on the totem pole. And so the documentary crew is just trying to follow up what happened to Dunder Mifflin and finds that it's part of this conglomerate. And they sort of stumble on an interesting story in the fact that this old newspaper is trying to be revived by an idealistic young publisher. and they think, oh, that'd be a good documentary, and they start following that. Well, I actually think that sounded pretty good for two ladies on a table with one microphone.
所以他们拥有邓德·米夫林，也就是经营办公用品的。但他们最大的产品是卫生纸和马桶座垫纸。此外，他们还拥有几家报纸。因为报纸也需要用纸，但报纸是赚钱最少的，在鄙视链里也是垫底的。于是，纪录片团队试图跟进邓德·米夫林后来的命运，发现它成了这家企业集团的一部分。他们偶然发现了一个有趣的故事，那就是这家老牌报纸正试图由一位有理想的年轻出版商重振。他们觉得，哦，这会是个不错的纪录片题材，于是便开始追踪报道。好吧，我觉得对于两个坐在桌子上、只拿着一个麦克风的女士来说，这番讲述已经相当不错了。
I know. And Greg, of course, always speaks so well. Yes. Okay. Well, Michael also shared with us, and the sound quality wasn't great on this. So, Michael, I'm just going to read it. I'm sorry. The table microphone set up slowly fell apart on us.
我知道。当然了，格雷格总是能把话说得这么漂亮。是的。好吧，迈克尔也跟我们分享了一些内容，不过这段的录音质量不是很好。所以，迈克尔的部分我就直接念出来吧。很抱歉。我们那个桌上麦克风的简易装置最后慢慢散架了。
Anyway, so Michael shared with us why they thought this story is timely. to what is happening right now in a lot of industries. He said that larger companies are acquiring newspapers, and often the newspapers will just function as a ghost paper. They're just sort of used for their name, and people recognize them as a source of news, but they mostly carry stories from the wire that you get on the Associated Press or any other big site,
总之，迈克尔跟我们分享了为什么他们认为这个故事非常切合时下许多行业正在发生的变化。他说，大公司正在收购报纸，通常这些报纸最后都只是沦为“幽灵报纸”。它们基本上只是借用一下名号，人们把它当成新闻来源，但它们刊登的大多是从美联社或其他大网站获取的通稿，
and they just milk them for ads until they disappear. And basically, they keep the newspapers around because they think it's good for the community, but they're not really servicing any new stories. And that just fit in perfectly with the premise of the paper. Well, Greg also shared about the comedy hook of this premise, which is that this dying newspaper only has one reporter. But the new publisher that we're going to meet in this first episode has a lot of ideas
然后榨干它们的广告价值，直到它们消亡。基本上，他们保留这些报纸是因为觉得这对社区有好处，但它们并没有真正提供任何新的报道。这与《真实信使报》的设定完美契合。好吧，格雷格还分享了这个设想中的喜剧噱头，那就是这家垂死的报纸只有一名记者。然而，我们在第一集里将要见到的这位新出版商却有很多想法，
about wanting to do original local coverage, but he doesn't have the money to hire reporters. Yeah, so we find out he gets volunteers from the people who already work there. truck drivers, salesmen, accountants, those are the people that become his news team. And, of course, they're total amateurs and, you know, hilarity ensues. Yes. Spoiler alert, there's a later episode where they invite a bunch of kids in the journalism department of the local college to, like, shadow the newspaper. And you realize that these journalism students know way more, way more than this rag-tag group of local reporters at this. And I really, that was really funny. I know. I love that whatever, when you see
想要做原创的本地报道，但他却没有资金去聘请记者。没错，所以我们发现他从已经在那里工作的人当中招募志愿者。卡车司机、销售员、会计，这些人成了他的新闻团队。当然，他们全都是业余新手，然后，你知道的，笑料百出。是的，剧透预警，后面有一集他们邀请了当地大学新闻系的一群学生来“实习”观摩报纸的运作。你会发现这些新闻系学生懂得的知识，比这群乌合之众般的本地报社记者要多得多，多得多。真的，那一幕真的太搞笑了。我知道。我喜欢无论何时你看到这一幕时，
it, one character says, can we come and shadow you guys at school? Yeah, like in your class? Because I'm learning a lot. Amazing. Well, fast fact number two, Greg shared with us that he really did try to recreate the magic that we had on the office. And some of that was in hiring a lot of the same crew members. So when we visited, we saw a lot of familiar faces. We sure did. And another thing that the office was famous for was having writers who also appeared in recurring roles on the show. And we asked Greg if that was the same thing for the paper. And he said, yeah, pretty much everything that seemed like good luck from back then, we tried to recreate. So we have four writer performers. And when we get into the show and we're doing our breakdown, I'll tell you who they are as we
其中一个角色会说：“我们能去你们学校观摩你们上课吗？”对，就像“在你们班里旁听”？因为我学到了很多。太棒了。好了，速览快讯第二条，格雷格跟我们分享说，他确实极力想要重现我们在《办公室》里曾有过的魔气。其中一部分就是雇用了许多原班人马的剧组人员。所以当我们探班时，我们看到了很多熟悉的面孔。我们确实看到了。办公室的另一个成名之处在于，它的编剧中也有不少人在剧中客串常驻角色。我们问格雷格《真实信使报》是不是也采用了同样的模式。他说，是的，基本上当年所有看起来像是好运的元素，我们都尽量去重现。所以我们有四个身兼编剧的演员。等我们进入正片并开始逐集解析时，当他们的角色登场，我会告诉大家他们都是谁。
meet their characters. I love that Greg brought back so much of the philosophy of the office, and I think you see it on screen. We'll get to it. We're going to talk about it. But the paper, it feels like the office. Yeah. It's in the universe. It's in the world. Absolutely. Yeah. You feel it on screen. Yeah. Well, Jenna, you've got FastFact three and two words. Oscar Nunez. Yes. Oscar's character is the head. head accountant for Enervate. Head accountant, excuse me? Yeah.
我很高兴格雷格带回了《办公室》里那么多的创作理念，而且我想你在银幕上就能看出来。我们会聊到这个的。我们接下来会讨论。但《真实信使报》确实很有《办公室》的感觉。是的。它属于同一个宇宙。它就在那个世界里。绝对是的。是的。你在屏幕上能感受到这一点。是的。好吧，珍娜，你手里有第三条速览快讯，而且只需要两个字：奥斯卡·努涅斯（Oscar Nunez）。是的。奥斯卡饰演的角色是 Enervate 公司的首席会计师。首席会计师，对不起，你说什么？是的。
Uh-huh. Yeah, there's three accountants again, but this time, Oscar is the head accountant. Looky, looky at Oscar. Yeah. The accountants cover all of the accounting for Enervate, which is the company that owns both the toilet paper side and the newspaper side. Mm-hmm. And, you know, last time we saw Oscar, he was running for state senator.
呃-哈。是的，这次又是三个会计师，但不同的是，奥斯卡成了首席会计师。瞧瞧奥斯卡出息了。是的。会计部门负责 Enervate 公司的所有财务，这家公司既拥有卫生纸业务，也拥有报纸业务。嗯-hmm。而且，你知道的，我们上次见到奥斯卡时，他正在竞选州参议员。
And Greg said that didn't pan out. So now the fact that Oscar is working at. at this newspaper is sort of his way of serving the community, and you're going to see that in his character. Again, I don't want to give too many spoilers. You don't want to give too much away, but I would say Oscar's New Journey has a little bit of Finer Things Club and a little bit of his heart for service. Yes. Well, we saw Oscar that day on the set, and it was so fun to see him in character again. Yeah, we should say we were there for the taping of episode 8, but we were there on set while Oscar was doing a scene.
格雷格说那次竞选没有成功。所以现在奥斯卡在这家报纸工作，某种程度上成了他服务社区的方式，你在他的角色身上就能看到这一点。再说一次，我不想剧透太多。你不想泄露太多内容，但我要说的是，奥斯卡的新征程里既有一点“精致生活俱乐部”的影子，又有一点他服务社区的热心肠。是的。好吧，那天我们在片场见到了奥斯卡，再次看到他进入角色真的太有趣了。是的，我们应该说，我们去的时候是在拍第八集，当时我们正在片场看奥斯卡拍一场戏。
And we got to sit back in Video Village with Greg and watch Oscar in a scene. Yeah. And Dave Rogers was directing. It was so magical. It felt like a little travel back in time. But we reached out to Oscar for this episode, and we asked him a few questions. First one was, how did you get your job on the paper? Ooh, yes.
我们得以和格雷格一起坐在视频监视村里观看奥斯卡的表演。是的。而且是戴夫·罗杰斯在执导。太神奇了。感觉就像是一次小小的时光倒流。不过为了这一集，我们联系了奥斯卡，向他提出了几个问题。第一个问题是：你是怎么得到《真实信使报》的工作的？哦，是的。
So I have lunch once in a while with Greg Daniels, our showrunner from the office. And months ago, we went out and he said something like Oscar. I'm thinking of an idea of something, I don't know, a startup with a newspaper or something like that, a paper in the world of journalism, like an old newspaper or something. And I, how would you feel if your character somehow bled over into that world or was part of that? And I said, yeah, that's fine. It was very, just very shallow, you know, an idea that he had. And then time went by weeks and maybe we had another lunch and it was a little bit more fleshed out. And this happened a couple times until finally he's like, when did you come by?
所以呢，我偶尔会和我们在《办公室》的剧集运作人格雷格·丹尼尔斯一起吃午饭。几个月前，我们出去吃饭时，他说起了类似这样的话：“奥斯卡，我脑子里有个想法，某个点子，我不知道，比如围绕报纸的一个创业项目之类的，或者诸如此类的事情，一个新闻界背景的报纸，比如一份老牌报纸什么的。如果你的角色不知怎么地融入到那个世界里，或者成为其中的一部分，你觉得怎么样？”我说：“行啊，这挺好的。”当时这非常随意，你知道的，只是他脑中的一个想法。然后时间一天天过去，几周后，我们可能又一起吃了一次午饭，这个想法变得更加丰满了。这种情况发生了好几次，直到最后他说：“你什么时候顺便过来一下？”
And they had an office down on Robertson. and I went by and there was the writing team and that's when I knew oh this thing is kind of happening and so it was a writing team and then he started to talk about Greg Daniels started to talk about possible people that he had in mind and fleshing out the idea more and that's how I found out about it in increments and I was sworn to secrecy from the beginning of course so then of course we had to ask him about keeping that secret yeah that's a big secret Here's what he said. Angela, as you know, Jenna might know, but Angela, definitely, I'm not good at keeping secrets.
他们在罗伯逊（Robertson）那边有一间办公室，我顺道去了一趟，编剧团队就在那里，那时我才知道，哦，这事儿好像真的要成了。当时是一个编剧团队，然后格雷格·丹尼尔斯开始谈论他心目中可能的人选，并进一步完善这个想法，我就是这样一点一点得知这件事的。当然了，从一开始我就宣誓要绝对保密。所以，毫无疑问，我们后来不得不问他关于保守这个秘密的事情。是的，这可是个惊天大秘密。他是这么说的。安吉拉，如你所知，珍娜可能也知道，但安吉拉，有一说一，我真的很不擅长保守秘密。
And it was very difficult. When we shot the pilot, Chris Hasten was there, which is Kate Flannery's boyfriend and photographer. He's a professional photographer, and he was there. And he's like, Oscar, oh, my God. And, you know, Greg Daniels told him, you have to keep it a secret. And he's like, oh, I've been doing this for a long time. And he found it very easy to keep the secret from Kate because he's been doing this. photography for 40 years with all kinds of celebrities and whatnot. But it was fun to see him there
这真的太难了。我们在拍试播集的时候，克里斯·海斯顿（Chris Hasten）也在场，他也就是凯特·弗兰纳里（Kate Flannery）的男朋友兼摄影师。他是一名专业摄影师，当时也在现场。他当时说：“奥斯卡，天呐。”然后，你知道的，格雷格·丹尼尔斯对他说：“你必须严守秘密。”他当时说：“哦，我干这行很久了。”他发现对凯特保密其实挺容易的，因为他过去 40 年来一直都在为各种名流之类的人拍照。不过很高兴能在现场看到他，而且我们俩共同保守了这个秘密。但我做到了。我想我确实做到了。然后，你知道的，在他们准备好官宣之前，消息还是走漏了。某个记者嗅到了风声。所以，我们就这样了。
and we had that secret together. But I did it. I think I did it. And then, you know, the cat got let out of the bag before we, they were ready to announce it. Some reporter got wind of it. And so here we are. Well, I remember when we saw that article, Angela, but that was not news to us because, you know, a while back, we ran into someone who we won't say. We can't say. We'll never. say. Accidentally let it slip about Oscar to us. I know. And we said we won't, we promise.
好吧，我记得当我们看到那篇文章时，安吉拉，但这对外我们来说并不是什么新闻，因为，你知道的，不久前，我们碰到了一个人，具体是谁我们就保密了。我们不能说。我们永远不会说。无意中向我们透露了关于奥斯卡的消息。我知道。当时我们说我们绝对不说，我们保证。
We promise. And we locked it down. We did. No one knows until right now that we knew. That's right. Like, no one. Yeah, lady, and I would see Oscar at all of these, like, things that our daughters were doing together, and I pretended like I didn't know he was on the paper.
我们保证。而且我们把消息捂得死死的。确实如此。直到现在，除了我们知道之外，根本没人知道。没错。就像，真的没人知道。是的，女士，我会在女儿们一起参加的各种活动上遇到奥斯卡，我当时还假装自己根本不知道他在拍那部报纸剧。
He had no idea you knew. Me and Brian and him talked about doing a fan convention together. I had no idea. No. Brian didn't know. Nobody knew. Yep. You know why?
他完全不知道你知道。我和布莱恩（Brian）还跟他聊过一起去参加粉丝见面会的事。我当时完全不知道。不知道。布莱恩也不知道。谁都不知道。没错。你知道为什么吗？
Because we locked it down. We locked it down. We locked it down. And I'm like so curious to ask Kate. Like, Kate, your longtime partner knew about this was taking pictures on the set. When did you find out? I need a follow-up question with Kate now. Well, yeah.
因为我们把消息捂得死死的。我们捂得死死的。我们捂得死死的。我简直太好奇想去问问凯特了。比如，凯特，跟你多年的伴侣明明知道这件事，还在片场拍了照。你是什么时候知道的？我现在得去追问凯特一个后续问题了。好吧，是的。
Because we didn't know. We, I didn't tell anyone. I didn't tell anyone. Kate, certainly. Oscar. Elie? Ellie. Ellie didn't tell anyone?
因为我们根本不知道。我们，我没有告诉任何人。凯特肯定也不知道。奥斯卡？艾丽？艾丽。艾丽也没有告诉任何人吗？
We had dinner with Ellie. We're like, how's it going? She's like, oh, you know. What? We, what? She didn't say a word. That's how tight this community is. Yeah.
我们和艾丽一起吃过晚饭。我们当时问：“最近怎么样？”她说：“哦，你知道的。”什么？我们，什么？她一个字都没透露。这就是这个圈子有多守口如瓶。是的。
Well, everyone in their... Well, I guess except for the one person who told us about Oscar. I know. Well, everyone who knew was very protective of it. Yes. And then ultimately, you know, a reporter found out, I am not surprised. though, because it's such a huge secret to keep for so long. And then they're filming at Universal Studios. We'll get to it. But there's like tour buses of people that go through there. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, there's so many people who could have seen Oscar at Universal Studios. It's a huge place. Yes.
好吧，每个人都在他们的……好吧，我猜除了那个把奥斯卡的消息透露给我们的家伙之外。我知道。好吧，所有知情的人都把这消息保护得很好。是的。然后到头来，你知道的，记者还是发现了，对此我一点也不感到意外。不过，要把这样一个惊天大秘密憋那么久，确实很难。而且他们当时还在环球影城（Universal Studios）拍戏。我们后面会聊到。那里经常有游客观光巴士穿梭而过。是的。是的。我的意思是，有那么多人可能会在环球影城看到奥斯卡。那地方可太大了。是的。
Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And then when we come back, we are going to talk all about the paper. Yep. the air, and with Pura, you can bring it into every room. From pumpkin spice to warm vanilla and apple cider, Pura partners with the brands you love to deliver premium fragrance in a smart diffuser you control from your phone. It's the perfect way to make your home and car cozy and inviting this season. Don't wait, discover smarter scenting today at Pura.com. Hey, y'all, I'm Maddie, And I'm Poodle. And together, we host the podcast Reality Gays. We are two ridiculous homosexuals who love nothing more than talking about reality television
好了，听着，我们为什么不休息一下呢？等我们回来，我们要好好聊聊《真实信使报》这部剧。没错。弥漫在空气中，而有了 Pura，你可以把它带到家里的每一个房间。从南瓜拿铁到温暖的香草和苹果酒，Pura 与你喜爱的品牌合作，通过可通过手机控制的智能扩香器为你提供优质的香氛。这是在这个季节让你的家和汽车变得温馨迷人的绝佳方式。不要等待，今天就到 Pura.com 体验更聪明的香氛科技。嘿，各位，我是麦迪（Maddi），我是普多尔（Poodle）。我们共同主持播客节目 Reality Gays。我们是两个荒谬的同性恋，最喜欢的事就是谈论真人秀节目，
and tearing in a new one. So whether it's 90-day fiancé, love is blind, love after lockup, or any other trash TV show about lonely hearts looking for love, your gay besties got you cover, Joe. New shows every week. Follow and listen to Reality Gays wherever you get your podcast. show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, sometimes we turn to some funny places for support, maybe a hairdresser, a barista, maybe a random stranger in the bathroom for life advice, but not everyone is a therapist. You can find your right match with BetterHelp. BetterHelp
并把它们扒得体无完肤。所以无论是《双料星期三》（90 Day Fiancé）、《爱情盲白》（Love Is Blind）、《狱后爱》（Love After Lockup），还是任何其他关于渴望爱情的孤独心灵的垃圾电视节目，你的好基友们全包了，乔。每周都有新节目。无论你在哪里收听播客，都可以关注并收听 Reality Gays。本期节目由 BetterHelp 赞助播出。你知道，有时候我们会向一些奇怪的地方寻求支持，比如美发师、咖啡师，或是浴室里碰到的陌生人来获取人生建议，但并不是每个人都是心理治疗师。你可以通过 BetterHelp 找到真正适合你的匹配对象。BetterHelp
therapists are clinically trained and credentialed. They work according to a strict code of conduct and are fully licensed in the U.S. And BetterHelp does. does the initial matching work for you? So you can focus on your therapy goals. You'll get a short questionnaire that helps identify your needs and preferences, and then they will match you with a licensed therapist. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Find the one with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month
的治疗师都经过临床培训并持有专业资质。他们遵循严格的行为准则，并在美国拥有完全的执业资格。BetterHelp 会为你完成最初的匹配工作。这样你就可以专注于你的心理治疗目标。你会收到一份简短的问卷，帮助确定你的需求和偏好，然后他们会为你匹配一位有执业资格的治疗师。作为全球最大的在线心理治疗提供商，BetterHelp 能够为你提供拥有各种专业专长的心理健康专业人士。通过 BetterHelp 找到对的人。我们的听众在 BetterHelp.com/officeladies 首次订阅可享九折优惠。
at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterHelp H-E-L-P-com slash office ladies. All right, we're back. And the paper opens with words on a screen. Yeah, it's a title card and there's a message. The message says, in 2005,
网址是 BetterHelp H-E-L-P 点 com 斜杠 office ladies。好了，我们回来了。《真实信使报》开场时屏幕上出现了一行字。是的，这是一个片名字幕，上面有一条信息。信息写着：在 2005 年，
a documentary crew started filming at a paper company in Scranton, Pennsylvania. They followed the workers in an average office dealing with new rules of workplace behavior and the ups and downs of their personal lives. And then it says, 20 years later, they returned. And the first thing the documentary crew
一个纪录片团队开始在宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿的一家纸业公司进行拍摄。他们追踪记录了一家普通办公室里的员工，看他们如何应对职场行为的新规则以及个人生活的起起落落。随后上面写道：20 年后，他们回来了。而这个离开长达 20 年的纪录片团队
who's been gone for 20 years shows us is the Scranton Business Park. The exterior of our building. That's right. It's the parking lot. There are four business signs listed, a little bit of a foreshadowing here. The businesses listed are Vance Refrigeration, one and done laser eye surgery and tattoo removal, Rubens, and Cavala. Yeah.
向我们展示的第一幕就是斯克兰顿商务园（Scranton Business Park）。我们大楼的外景。没错。那是停车场。画面上列出了四个商业招牌，这里其实埋下了一点点伏笔。列出的企业有：万斯制冷（Vance Refrigeration）、一次搞定激光视力矫正与文身清除中心（One and Done Laser Eye Surgery and Tattoo Removal）、鲁本斯（Rubens）和卡瓦拉（Cavala）。是的。
And now the camera crew starts to push into those doors that we know, those glass doors. One background catch here as we scan the parking lot, everything looks the same except there are now electric car chargers. I didn't even notice that. Yeah. Oh, I love that detail. Yeah, we are going to go inside and guess where we start. This was such a surprise, and I loved it so much. We're at Vance Refrigeration, and we are warmly greeted by Bob Vance.
现在摄像机团队开始推镜头走向那些我们熟知的玻璃门。在扫描停车场时有一个背景细节，一切看起来都一模一样，除了现在多出了电动汽车充电桩。我甚至都没注意到这一点。是的。哦，我很喜欢这个细节。是的，我们要走进去了，猜猜我们从哪里开始。这真是个惊喜，我太喜欢了。我们来到了万斯制冷，并受到了鲍勃·万斯（Bob Vance）的热烈欢迎。
Bobby Ray Schaefer. Mm-hmm. Bobby Ray does such a great job. Bob Vance is going to have a talking head. He says, hey, Dundra Mifflin's been gone for a while. Phyllis and Stanley keep in touch. They've both got the same kind of dog, a schnoodle. Yeah.
鲍比·雷·谢弗（Bobby Ray Schaefer）。嗯-hmm。鲍比·雷表现得太棒了。鲍勃·万斯将有一个访谈镜头。他说，嘿，邓德·米夫林已经离开好一阵子了。菲利斯（Phyllis）和斯坦利（Stanley）一直保持着联系。他们都养了同一种狗，叫施诺多犬（Schnoodle）。是的。
And he says, you know, the one and done guys are less drama. And you're kind of like, who are the one and done guys? Yeah, what's one and done? Well, we go down the hall to where the Dundra Mifflin offices were. Yeah, we go past the elevator and we open that door. And first of all, there's no carpeting. It's now hardwood floors. Oh, I didn't notice that.
他说，你知道的，那些“一次搞定”的人少了很多抓马。然后你就会想：什么是“一次搞定”的人？是的，什么是“一次搞定”？好吧，我们顺着走廊来到了曾经的邓德·米夫林办公室所在地。是的，我们走过电梯，推开那扇门。首先，地毯不见了。现在换成了硬木地板。哦，我没注意到这个。
Yeah. Reception desk is completely different. It's like metal and shiny. Yeah, it has like, what do you, like LED lights on it. Yeah. Yeah, it's very modern. Very modern, very slick looking. Yes. And yeah, it's a laser eye company and laser tattoo removal. Yes. So the documentary crew clocks this and then they go back to talk to Bob. Yeah. He's going to get on his computer and he's going to explain that Dunder Mithelam was purchased in 2009. by a company called Enervate in Ohio. They asked if Phyllis wanted to leave and move to Toledo, go with the company. And Phyllis was like, yeah, right, forget it. She's like, leave Scranton? Yeah. No.
是的。前台完全变了。看起来像是金属材质的，亮闪闪的。对，上面还有类似，你懂的，LED灯带。是的。是的，非常现代。非常现代，看起来非常时髦。是的。而且，是的，这是一家激光视力矫正公司和激光文身清除公司。是的。所以纪录片团队注意到了这一点，然后他们回去找鲍勃交谈。是的。他坐在电脑前解释说，邓德·米夫林是在 2009 年被俄亥俄州一家名叫 Enervate 的公司收购的。他们问菲利斯是否愿意离职搬到托莱多去，跟着公司一起走。而菲利斯的反应是：得了吧，拉倒吧。她说：离开斯克兰顿？是的。才不呢。
I have two background catches. For my folks that love a background catch, Bob Vance has a post-it note on his computer. It's on the top left corner. It's orange. And it says in handwriting, 10% discount only on fridges, not labor. Oh. So you're not going to get a discount on labor. Also, the Chamber of Commerce website is on the screen. If you go to it because I did, it is not an active website. Oh. They didn't set up fakey website. Got it. Here's something I thought of. If Dunder Mifflin was sold in 2019,
我有两个背景彩蛋。对于喜欢寻找背景彩蛋的观众朋友们，鲍勃·万斯的电脑上贴了一张便利贴。它在左上角。是橙色的。上面手写着：10% 折扣仅限冰箱，不含人工费。哦。所以你在人工费上是拿不到折扣的。此外，屏幕上显示的是商会（Chamber of Commerce）的网站。如果你去访问它——因为我去了——你会发现它并不是一个活动的网站。哦。他们没有弄一个假的网站。明白了。这里有件事我一直在想。如果邓德·米夫林是在 2019 年被卖掉的，
that means it was sold before the pandemic. Oh. So Dwight never had to deal with like COVID rule. Here's my question. Yes. Does Dwight still own the Scranton Park, though? Oh, does he still own the building? Yeah, because he bought the whole building. You're right. Yeah.
那就意味着它是在大流行之前被卖掉的。哦。所以德怀特（Dwight）从来不用应付像新冠防疫规定那样的事情。我的问题是：是的。不过德怀特现在还拥有斯克兰顿商务园吗？哦，他还在经营那栋楼吗？是的，因为他把整栋楼都买下来了。你说的对。是的。
We don't know the answer to that right now. We don't. Mm-mm. I secretly hope he does. Well, I just loved that the show opens with a familiar face. I love hearing that Stanley and Phyllis both have schnoodles. You know, I was just sort of. on the edge of my seat when I saw Bobby. I know. We did not know he was part of the show.
我们现在还不知道答案。我们不知道。嗯-mm。我暗暗希望他依然拥有。好吧，我只是太喜欢这部剧以一 张熟悉的面孔开场了。听到斯坦利和菲利斯都养了施诺多犬，我太开心了。你知道的，我当时简直有点。坐在椅子边缘期待着。当我看到鲍比时。我知道。我们事先并不知道他是这部剧的一部分。
We did not. We did not. Oscar, but I did not know about Bobby. Also, did you have to Google schnoodles because I did. No, I just assumed they were like a schnauzer and a poodle. That's exactly what they are. I mean, it's like a Labradoodle is like a Labrador and a poodle. I guess it didn't click for me what a schnoodle was. I didn't know you could mix a schnauzer and a poodle. I didn't either. How does that work? I don't know and I don't want to think about it. Okay. But back to Bobby Ray for a second. So you guys, we did an AT&T commercial. It's out in the world now.
我们不知道。我们完全不知道。奥斯卡我知道，但我不知道鲍比也会参演。另外，你们有没有去谷歌一下什么是施诺多犬，因为我查了。没有，我只是以为它们是雪纳瑞（Schnauzer）和贵宾犬（Poodle）的混血。它们确实就是。我的意思是，就像拉布拉多贵宾犬（Labradoodle）是拉布拉多和贵宾犬的混血一样。我猜我当时没反应过来施诺多犬是什么。我不知道雪纳瑞和贵宾犬还能串种。我也不知道。那是怎么做出来的？我不知道，我也不想去细想。好吧。不过我们还是说回鲍比·雷。所以各位，我们拍了一个 AT&T 的广告。现在已经在全球上线了。
You will have seen some of it. It's so good. It's so funny, lady. They're so fun. You did him as well. They've really gotten almost the entire cast. Yeah. Well, we were on set one day, and we were just chatting.
你们应该已经看过了其中的一部分。拍得太棒了。太好笑了，女士。他们真的太有趣了。你也拍了。他们几乎把整个演员阵容都请齐了。是的。好吧，有一天我们在片场，大家就在闲聊。
I was asking him how his life is. He has a very peaceful existence on this nice big property in West Virginia. And we exchanged phone numbers. And when I watched this, I was like, oh, my gosh, Bobby Ray was in it and didn't even and tell me. There you go. There you go. So I texted him, and I was like, can you please share with us what it was like to be on the paper? And he sent us in this lovely audio clip. Let's hear it. Hello to the office ladies, Angela and Jenna, and your loyal listeners. This is Bobby Ray Schaefer, aka Bob Vance, to answer for refrigeration. I'm pleased to join you today to talk about my experience
我问他现在的生活过得怎么样。他在西弗吉尼亚州一处美丽的大庄园里过着非常平静的生活。我们交换了电话号码。当我看到这一集时，我就想：哦，天呐，鲍比·雷竟然参演了，甚至都没有提前告诉我。就是这样。就是这样。所以我给他发了条短信，对他说：你能跟我们分享一下参与拍摄《真实信使报》是什么体验吗？他给我们发来了一段非常可爱的音频。我们来听听。向《办公室》女士安吉拉和珍娜以及你们的忠实听众问好。我是鲍比·雷·谢弗，也就是万斯制冷的鲍勃，负责制冷业务。很高兴今天能加入你们，聊聊我参与拍摄新电视剧《真实信使报》的经历。当时我正坐在西弗吉尼亚州树林里山顶的房子里，安分守己地过着自己的日子。我当时正在创作我的自传，我确信听众们一定会喜欢它的书名，书名叫作：《鲍勃，你是做什么工作的？》当然，这本书讲述了我职业生涯中从事过的一切工作，其中当然包括最著名、最受大家喜爱的《办公室》，这都要感谢史上最棒的粉丝们。所以有一天早晨，我收到了一封电子邮件，我打开一看，是来自好莱坞的。我会感兴趣吗？我有空参与格雷格·丹尼尔斯的新项目吗？
filming the new TV show, The Paper. There I was in my house on the hill, in the woods, in West Virginia, minding my own business. And I was working on my autobiography, which I'm sure the listeners will delight in the title, which is, what line of work are you in Bob? Of course, it's about all the jobs that I had in my career, including the most famous and loved of the mall, the office, thanks to the greatest fans ever. So I receive an email in my inbox one morning, and I opened it up, and it's from Hollywood. Would I be interested? Would I be available for a new Greg Daniels project?
好吧，这个答案只有一个，那就是：当然愿意。所以我回复说我的档期完全没问题。然后我就得等上一段时间了。女士们，你们知道那种感觉。当时我想，在我离开洛杉矶经历了 40 年的摸爬滚打之后，我再也不会回去了。但当然，正如我联系我的制片人时所说的那样，我从来没有拒绝过格雷格·丹尼尔斯，现在也不会开始拒绝。
Well, there's only one answer to that, and it is, of course, yes. So I send back my availability is total. And then I had to wait for a while. You know how that goes, ladies. And at the time I had thought when I left L.A., after 40 years of grinding, that I would never go back. But, of course, as I told the producer who contacted me, I've never said no to Greg Daniels, and I'm not going to start now.
所以在经过大约一个月的“到底能不能成？会不会泡汤？”的等待之后，我又回到了那种纠结的心态中：到底行不行，是不是要拍了。你知道的，这对演员来说简直就是一种折磨。但在有一段时间不用经历这些之后，说实话，重新回到这种状态感觉还挺有趣的。最终合同敲定了，
So after about a month of, is it going to happen? Is it not going to happen? And I found myself right back in the old mindset of it is, it isn't, it is, it is. And, you know, that's torture for an actor. but after not having to go through it for a while, it was kind of fun to be back in it to tell you the truth. And the deal was closed. The arrangements were made,
一切安排妥当，我发现自己正坐在一架大客机上飞往西海岸。第二天早上我来到了片场，要我说，《办公室》和《真实信使报》最大的区别就在于，因为拍摄是在环球影城外景地进行的。当我走出门车时，你知道的，观光游览车会从旁边缓缓开过，所有的人都在挥手、盯着你看、大喊大叫。这为拍摄增添了一个全新的维度。不管怎样，能回到万斯制冷的办公室真是太棒了。如你们所知，细节在《办公室》里至关重要，在《真实信使报》里同样如此，因为这是一个完美的复刻，从秘书到整个办公室，
and I found myself on a big old jet plane to the coast. I went to the set the next morning, and I'd say that was the biggest difference in the office and the paper is that being on the universal lot. When I would walk out of my trailer, you know, the tour carts would come rolling by and all the people were waving and staring and yelling. And that was a new dimension to filming. But anyway, it was fantastic to be back in the Vance Refrigeration office. As you know, details are key on the office and they are too on the paper because it was a perfect replica right down to a secretary and the whole.
一切都一模一样。你知道的，那一刻我真正体会到了什么是似曾相识的感觉。我的意思是，你知道的，我以前就去过那里，但很高兴能看到所有的……除了丹尼尔斯先生之外，还有许多剧组老熟人，比如我们的餐饮主管塞尔吉奥（Sergio），他也一直在那里，见到他真的很高兴，还有剧本主管维达（Veda）和剪辑师戴夫·罗杰斯。所以感觉就像是老友重聚。这种感觉真的很美妙，能再次与这群伟大而又才华横溢的人共事。而且格雷格亲自执导了试播集。所以我得以和他度过了一段美好的时光。他写了一个非常聪明、搞笑的开场。
office you know i i really knew then what deja vu felt like i mean you know i'd been there before but it was delightful to see all the uh there were many of the crew members and the key guy of course other than mr daniels was sergio our caterer and he was there and it was a delight to see him and veda the script supervisor and dave rogers the editor and so it was like old home And it was really just a wonderful feeling to be back involved with those great people, so talented. And Greg was directing the pilot. And so I got to spend some quality time with him. And he had written a very smart, funny open.
希望你们大家都会喜欢。我之所以参演的主要原因，当然除了因为是格雷格的项目之外。还有它与《办公室》的历史渊源。如你们所知，正如你们许多人所知，我一直在参加很多粉丝见面会。我不得不说，我还是要再强调一次，我们拥有电视节目史上最棒的粉丝。我要非常感谢你们所有人，让我们感到自己如此珍贵和备受宠爱。这真的是一项巨大的荣誉。而且，能够仅仅通过一张照片和签名就能给人们带来快乐，这真是一种福气。而你们给了我这一切。所以，《办公室》女士们，
I hope you'll all enjoy it. And the main reason I did it, of course, other than, you know, it was Greg. And it's the historical link with the office. As you know, as many of you know, I've been doing a lot. lot of fan shows. And I have to say, I'll say it again, we do have the greatest fans in television show history. And I want to thank you all very much for making us feel so treasured and cherished. It's really, truly a great honor. And it's, it's been a blessing to be able to make people happy with just a photo and a signature. And you gave me that. So office ladies,
你们正在大显身手，再接再厉。非常爱你们，回头见。拜拜。哦，太棒了，真的太棒了。我太喜欢这一切了。我给他发短信说：我们俩非常感谢你。他说：好吧，安吉，谢谢你，不过你要知道我原谅你曾经往我身上吐口水了。
you're kicking butt, taking names, keep it up. Love you very much, and I'll see you. Bye-bye. Oh, that's not great. So great. I just loved all of that. And I texted him, thank you so much from the two of us. And he said, well, Ange, thank you and know that I forgive you for spitting on me.
我说：等等，你在说什么？我什么时候往你身上吐口水了？太对不起了。我猜我真的是个冒失鬼。我还以为也许是我在拍 AT&T 广告时吐的呢。好吧。他回信说：哈哈，是“Fun Run”（趣味长跑那一集）。我当时对那只死猫发表了评论。
And I said, wait, what are you talking about? When did I spit on you? I'm so sorry. I guess I'm a hot mess. I thought maybe I spit on him on the AT&D commercial. Okay. And he wrote back and he said, ha, ha, fun run. I made a remark about the dead cat.
那是被删减的片段。哦，天呐。我当时只是在开玩笑。所以现在我想回去重温“Fun Run”的删减片段，然后感叹：我居然把那一幕忘得精光。好吧，格雷格告诉我，他们回到了我们老的外景地，为那个开场建立镜头恢复了斯克兰顿商务园的招牌。他说那天有一些粉丝正好在那里。他们过来拍了照。他说他们真的很幸运，因为你知道的，那个招牌平时并不挂在那栋楼上。他说
It was a deleted scene. Oh, my gosh. And I was just teasing. So now I want to go back to Fun Run deleted scenes and be like, I totally forgot that scene. Well, Greg told me that they went back to our old lot and they restored the Scranton Business sign park for that opening, establishing. shot. And he said that on that day, some fans were there. And they came and took photos. He was like, they got really lucky because, you know, that sign is not usually there on the building. He said
再次看到它挂在那里感觉真的很酷。但就像鲍比说的，万斯制冷、眼科中心和电梯，所有这些都是他们在环球影城外景地的声音舞台上完全重建的，因为《真实信使报》就是在环球影城外景地的声音舞台上拍摄的。没错。我们去那里参观过。而且，你知道的，那天结束时我们正走向汽车。格雷格人太好了。我们参观完后，他亲自送我们出来。我们就站在车旁。然后其中一辆观光车就开过去了。是的，就是鲍比提到的那种。是的，那是一辆露天巴士，上面坐着许多来环球影城参观的游客。你买了通票，就能参观整个外景地。而我们当时就站在那里。格雷格真的就像是说：快趴下，看着我们，赶紧躲到一个垃圾桶后面。我们真的扑倒在一个垃圾桶后面，因为我们不想让别人看到我们在那儿。我们当时很害怕。和格雷格在一起。是的，因为当时有传言说《真实信使报》要开拍了。是的。而且，是的。
it was just kind of cool to see it there again. But like Bobby said, the vance refrigeration and the eye center and the elevator, all of that, they completely rebuilt on a soundstage at the universal lot because that's where they shot the paper was on a soundstage at the universal lot. That's right. And we went and visited there. And, you know, we were walking to our cars at the end of the day. Greg was so sweet. He walked us out after our visit. We're standing by the cars. And one of those buses went by. Yeah, that Bobby talked about. Yeah. It's like an open air bus with a bunch of visitors who are coming to Universal Studios. You pay for this past. You get the tour of the whole back lot. And there we were standing there. And Greg literally was like, get to you.
不过我必须得说，现在听说有人在我们的老片场拍下了那个斯克兰顿商务园的招牌。是的。伙计们，放大照片看看。我敢打赌你们能找到“一次搞定”激光公司。你们大概率能找到。好吧，既然我们的纪录片团队已经弄清楚了邓德·米夫林是被 Enervate 收购的，我们就要前往 Enervate 了。去托莱多。是的，去“真实信使报大厦”（Truth Teller Tower）。我们上楼，看到一群工人在这些玻璃墙的隔间里。其中一个人正在刮胡子。他拿着一个电动剃须刀，半躺着一边刮胡子。
down, look at us, dive behind like a dumpster. We literally dove behind a dumpster because we did not want people to see us there. We were afraid. With Greg. Yes, that it would, because there were the rumors that the paper was happening. Yeah. And we, yes. Yeah.
他遭到了隔壁隔间那个人的一记斜眼。向史蒂芬·索克斯（Stephen Sox）致敬，他在剧中饰演那个刮脸的男士。你可能认得这个名字，因为我们多年来一直在谈论他和他的妻子洛瑞（Lori）。他们曾是《办公室》里的替身演员。他们俩都在《办公室》里客串过，看到他能参演《真实信使报》，我感到非常高兴。是的，女士，当我们去探班时，我们同时见到了史蒂芬和洛瑞，这太酷了，但我当时根本不知道他还有客串戏份。我也不知道。
But I have to say, hearing now that people took pictures of that Scranton Park sign at our old set. Yeah. Guys, zoom in. I bet you have laser one. done. You probably do. Yeah. Well, now that our documentary crew has figured out that Dunder Mitham was bought by Enervate, we're going to go to Enervate. To Toledo. Yes, to the Truth Teller Tower. And we go upstairs, and we're going to see a bunch of workers in these, like, glass-walled cubicles. And one of them is shaving. He's got an electric shaver, and he's reclining, kind of shaving.
因为每个人都把消息捂得严严实实的。所以当我们看这一集时，我发短信问他关于参与《真实信使报》工作的事。我问他和洛瑞是怎么加入《真实信使报》的，参与这部剧拍摄是什么体验，去客串是什么感觉。他给我们发来了一条最可爱的消息，就像鲍比·雷一样。每个人都太美好了。你一定要听听。
He's getting the side eye from the person in the cubicle next to him. Shout out to Stephen Sox, who played the man shaving his face. You might recognize that name because we have talked about him and his wife, Lori, for years. They were the stand-in team on the office. They both had cameos on the office, and I was so tickled to see him on the paper. Yes, lady, when we visited, we saw both Stephen and Lori, and it was so cool, but I had no idea that he had a cameo. Neither did I. because everybody locked it up.
我和洛瑞都有幸参与了《真实信使报》的工作。试播集真的非常令人激动。我的意思是，不知怎么的，我们俩居然都能在《办公室》工作那么多年，我们留下了太多的回忆；而一听说甚至有了一部真正意义上的《办公室》衍生剧，我们立刻就联系了格雷格·丹尼尔斯，他不仅人超级好，而且绝对才华横溢。就这样，我们得以参与到这部全新的剧集当中。好吧，有一天我在拍摄间隙，溜达着走到了我们正在使用的另一个片场，我看到了一个刚刚搭建好的布景的外观。从外面看，一个布景看起来无非就是木头、钉子，还有这儿那儿的门。直到你推开门走进去，布景才会真正呈现在眼前。当时那里空无一人，片场里连一个人影都没有。所以我孤身一人。我很好奇我们接下来几天会拍些什么。你知道的，那可能是一家餐厅、一套公寓或者别的什么。所以我推开其中一扇门，发现那是办公室的电梯大堂。我走进了那扇门，那是万斯制冷玻璃门旁边的楼梯间门，那一刻我瞬间被带回了过去
So when we watched this, I texted him about working on the paper. I asked him how him and Lori came to work on the paper, what it was like working on the show, what it was like to do this cameo. And he sent us the most lovely message, just like Bobby Ray. Everyone has just been so wonderful. You got to hear it.
所以当我们看这个的时候，我发短信给他，问他关于写论文的事。我问他和洛里是怎么开始写论文的，在节目里工作是什么感觉，客串是什么感觉。他给我们发了一条非常可爱的短信，就像鲍比·雷一样。每个人都太好了。你们一定要听听。
Lori and I both got to work on the paper. And the pilot episode was really a thrill. I mean, somehow, we were both able to work on the office for all those years and we made so many memories and as soon as we found out about there even being a true office spinoff we reached out to Greg Daniels who is just so kind and just absolutely brilliant and somehow we got to work on this brand new show well one day I had a break from filming and I walked over to one of the other stages we were using and I saw the outside of a set that had just been built. And from the outside, a set just looks like
我和洛里都有幸参与了这篇论文的工作。试播集真的非常激动人心。我的意思是，不知怎的，我们俩能在《办公室》工作那么多年，留下了那么多美好的回忆，而且我们一听说真的会有《办公室》的衍生剧，就立刻联系了格雷格·达尼尔斯，他既善良又绝对才华横溢，不知怎的，我们竟然有机会参与这部全新的剧集。有一天，我拍戏间隙休息，走到我们使用的另一个片场，看到了刚刚搭建好的一处布景的外观。从外面看，布景看起来就像
wood and nails and a door here and there. And it's not until you open the door and step inside that the set is revealed. There was no one else, not a single person on stage. And so I was all alone. And I was curious about what we might shoot the next few days. You know, it could have been a restaurant or an apartment or whatever. So I opened one of the doors and it was the office's elevator lobby. I had entered that door that was a stairwell door next to Bob Vance's glass door, and I was instantly taken back
木头、钉子和零星的门。直到你打开门走进去，布景才会展现在眼前。当时空无一人，片场里一个人也没有。所以我孤身一人。我对我们接下来几天要拍的内容很好奇。你知道，可能是一家餐厅、一公寓或者别的什么。于是我打开其中一扇门，发现那是办公室的电梯大厅。我走进了那扇门，那是鲍勃·万斯玻璃门旁边的楼梯间门，我瞬间被带回了过去
to the old Chandler Valley Studios in Van Nuys. It was shocking and emotional, actually. I walked up to the elevator and so many memories flooded my brain and I thought of one of the most vivid memories on the show. It was Steve Carell's last day and specifically Steve's last scene. The scene was when Michael says goodbye to the office and he walks to the elevator and exits the building. The day before Greg had asked me to wear a suit and so he put me in the scene. Me and a male guy,
来到范内斯的老钱德勒山谷制片厂。这其实挺震撼也挺让人感动的。我走向电梯，无数的回忆涌上心头，我想到了这部剧里最生动的回忆之一。那是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的最后一天，具体来说是史蒂夫的最后一场戏。那场戏是迈克尔向办公室告别，他走向电梯并离开大楼。前一天格雷格让我穿上一套西装，所以他把我安排进了这场戏。我和一个男性，
courier walk out of the elevator as Michael walks in on Steve's last take. I watched the character Michael Scott enter the elevator and the doors closed and then after the scene ended, the doors opened and the actor Steve Carell stepped out. It really was just him and I in the lobby at that point and I couldn't help myself and I just gave him a big hug. Well, here I was back in that space and I had goosebumps. I saw Bob Bance's office, and then I walked toward the Dunder Mifflin office, and it was a laser hair removal place.
快递员从电梯里走出来，而迈克尔在史蒂夫的最后一个镜头里走了进去。我看着角色迈克尔·斯科特走进电梯，电梯门关上了；接着戏拍完后，门又打开了，演员史蒂夫·卡瑞尔走了出来。当时大堂里真的只有我和他，我情不自禁地给了他一个大大的拥抱。好了，现在我又回到了那个空间，我起了一身鸡皮疙瘩。我看到了鲍勃·万斯办公室，然后我朝邓德米夫林办公室走去，结果那变成了一家激光脱毛店。
So it was, Dunder Mifflin was gone. And what I felt at that moment was just closure. Life moves on, and art shows us in amazing ways that life has changed. I got to stand there in that moment full of gratitude for all that the office meant to me and then in that same breath I got to pivot to this brand new show and then like the next day they asked me
所以，邓德米夫林已经没了。我当时感受到的只有释怀。生活在继续，艺术以奇妙的方式向我们展示了生活的变化。我有幸站在那里，心中充满了对“办公室”对我而言意味着的一切的感激，紧接着，我又得以转向这部全新的剧集。然后就像是第二天，他们问我
if I could come in and work with the talented Tim Key in one of the opening scenes of the pilot just an incredible experience that I will never forget That is so powerful. Well, I cried the first time I listened to that. Yeah. Because he's right about what art can show us. And I just can't imagine what it was like.
能不能来客串一下，和才华横溢的蒂姆·基一起拍试播集开头的几场戏——这绝对是一次我永远不会忘记的不可思议的经历。太有感染力了。我第一次听的时候都听哭了。对啊。因为他说得对，艺术能向我们展示生活的真谛。我简直无法想象当时那种感觉。
Like, it feels like time travel. If I could open a door and be standing in that elevator bay again. And I didn't know that story that he had that moment with Steve. Yeah. And then now he is there again, all these years later, in that same elevator bay. And, yeah, I thought Stephen said it all so well. Yeah.
就像是时间旅行。如果我也能打开一门，再次站在那个电梯间里。而且我之前不知道他跟史蒂夫有过那样一段故事。对啊。然后现在，时隔多年，他又回到了那个相同的电梯间。而且，对啊，我觉得斯蒂芬把这一切都表达得太好了。对啊。
I felt everything that he shared. You're a little teary. I, you know, yeah, it makes me so excited for this group of people. I just hope that this show gets to give them what the office gave us. Yeah. All right. Well, now we are going to cut to a talking head. of Ken. Ken is played by Tim Key. He is British. He is the head of strategy for the corporate offices
他分享的每一种感受我都感同身受。你有点想哭了。我，你知道的，对啊，这让我对这群演员充满期待。我只希望这部剧能带给他们《办公室》带给我们的那种体验。对啊。好了，现在我们要切到一个单人访谈。受访者是肯。肯由蒂姆·基饰演。他是英国人。他是企业总部的战略主管
at Enervate. And he's going to explain to us what Enervate does. Let's listen. Innovate sells products made out of paper. So that might be office supplies. There might be janitorial paper, which is toilet tissue, toilet seat protectors, and local newspapers. And that is in order of quality. I loved at the very end when he says, in order of quality, he thinks he's being funny. And he has this little smirk look to camera, and it just cracked me up. Now he's going to take us on the tour of the offices. He explains that the corporate offices are on the eighth floor.
就职于埃内尔维特公司。他要向我们解释埃内尔维特是做什么的。我们听听看。埃内尔维特销售纸制品。所以可能是办公用品。也可能是清洁用纸，比如卫生纸、马桶垫防护纸，以及地方报纸。这是按质量高低排序的。我最喜欢他在最后说“按质量高低排序”的那句，他觉得自己挺搞笑的。他对着镜头露出了一个坏笑，把我给逗乐了。现在他要带我们参观办公室了。他解释说企业办公室在八楼。
He's going to take us up to the ninth floor. This reminded me of our pilot where Michael Scott is taking you on a tour of Dunder Mifflin. because he starts introducing everybody. We find out that the ninth floor is home to Softie's toilet paper. And when he opens the door, by the way, this is when we get our first glimpse of the set. And it is huge. It's so vast. Yes, it is this big open space, but there are very few people in it.
他要带我们去九楼。这让我想起了我们的试播集，迈克尔·斯科特带你参观邓德米夫林的情景。因为他开始逐一介绍大家。我们发现九楼是“小软（Softie's）”卫生纸的地盘。当他打开门时——顺便说一下，我们第一次得以一窥片场全貌。真的好大。非常空旷。对，这是一个很大的开放空间，但里面没几个人。
Michael Komen told me that this scene was the very first scene they shot of the paper. Oh, really? Yes. Aw. Well, you know, as Ken walks through, he's greeting his Toilet Kings and one queen, who I think has a little bit of an Angela Martin vibe. She's got that ponytail pulled back tight. And I love the throwaway snarky comment, Ken said as he walked past her. He says, Scrunchy, no harm in it. Because she has her hair and a scrunchy. It was just a really funny throwaway line. Well, Scrunchy gal, aka Toilet Queen, is our first writer performer. She is,
迈克尔·科门告诉我，这场戏是他们拍这部剧时拍的第一场戏。哦，真的吗？是的。啊。嗯，你知道的，当肯走过去时，他在向他的“厕所之王”们打招呼，还有一位女王，我觉得她身上有点安吉拉·马丁的影子。她扎着一个紧紧的马尾辫。我特别喜欢肯从她身边走过时顺口说的一句讽刺的话。他说：“大肠圈发绳，无伤大雅嘛。”因为她用发圈扎着头发。这真是一句非常搞笑的随性台词。好吧，发圈妹，也就是“厕所女王”，是我们剧组的第一位编剧兼演员。她啊，
a character that we're going to see at Softies named Kimberly, and she is played by Mo Welch. Ken continues now to show us the rest of the Softies side of the office. There's a lot of old artwork and logos, and then he takes us to a gong that they hit whenever a sale is made. I have to imagine that's going to drive everyone crazy if you work there. And this is when he introduces us to what's on the other side of the office, which is the local newspaper, the Toledo Truth Teller. Yes. We find out that this entire building, which is a big building. Yes. It used to house the newspaper with a staff of like a thousand. And now they're just like half of this floor and there's like seven of them. Then we flash back to 1971. Yeah, we're going to
是我们在“小软”公司将要见到的一个角色，名叫金伯利，由莫·韦尔奇饰演。肯接着带我们参观办公室里“小软”那边的其他地方。那里有很多老旧的艺术品和标志，然后他带我们去看了一个每当达成一笔销售就会敲响的锣。我完全可以想象，如果你在那里上班，这玩意儿绝对能把人逼疯。接着他向我们介绍办公室另一边是什么，那就是地方报纸《托莱多实话实说报》。对。我们发现整栋楼——这是一栋大楼。对。以前是一家报社的所在地，员工有一千人左右。现在他们只占了这个楼层的一半，员工大概只有七个人。然后镜头闪回到1971年。对，我们要
watch a little black and white documentary. That's the year I was born. Guys, we did have color TV in I am not that old. I am 54. You're so right. It made me laugh. Anyway, I think we just needed to differentiate between our current day story and this, like, documentary. You're so right. Anyway, I'm sure that's exactly why they did it, but it did crack me up. Yeah, so we're watching this old documentary and it's being hosted by John Stack, the publisher of the Toledo Truth Teller, and we're seeing our same set, but now it is just filled with like wall-to-wall people.
看一小段黑白纪录片。那是我出生的年份。伙计们，我们那时候其实有彩色电视的好吗，我没那么老。我54岁了。你说得太对了。把我逗笑了。总之，我觉得我们只是需要把现代的故事和这个所谓的纪录片区分开来。你说得太对了。总之，我敢肯定这正是他们这样做的原因，但这确实把我逗乐了。对，所以我们正在看这部老纪录片，由《托莱多实话实说报》的出版商约翰·斯塔克主持，我们看到了同样的布景，但现在里面挤满了密密麻麻的人。
John Stack is played by Tracy Letts, lady. Lady, lady. Oh, your theater nerd heart went into overdrive. You were like, Angela, Angela. Tracy Letts, multiple Tony Award winner. He wrote August to Osage, County. He won a Tony for playing George in the revival of Who's Afraid of Virginia Wolf. I saw it. I saw all of it. I went to Chicago to see his play Superior Donuts at Steppenwolf. And lady,
约翰·斯塔克由特雷西·莱茨饰演，天哪。天哪，天哪。哦，你的戏剧迷心脏彻底狂跳了吧。你当时就像：“安吉拉，安吉拉。特雷西·莱茨，多次托尼奖得主。他写过《八月：奥色治郡》。他因在复排版《谁害怕弗吉尼亚·沃尔夫》中饰演乔治而赢得托尼奖。我看过。我全都看了。我甚至去芝加哥的斯泰彭沃尔夫剧场看了他的话剧《高级甜甜圈》。而且天哪，”
afterwards, I got to go out and have drinks with him. Wow. Did you keep your cool? Did you say anything ridiculous? I barely spoke. Okay, that's smart. That's smart. I was so nervous. Yes, yes. So I asked, Michael Coleman, I was like, how did you get Tracy Letts on the show? And Michael Coleman was like as big of a nerd about him as I was. And he said he was my first choice. So they just reached out. And he said yes. And Michael was like I was genuinely thrilled. Well, now the scene that's going to come at the end makes perfect sense to me. Uh-huh. We'll get to that. We'll get to it. Because of Michael's love of him. Well, he absolutely adores him. He said they actually shot a ton of stuff with him, and he really hopes that they're going to be able to keep weaving this old,
事后我有幸和他一起出去喝了杯酒。哇。你当时有保持冷静吗？没有说出什么离谱的话吧？我几乎没怎么说话。好吧，那挺明智的。那挺明智的。我当时紧张得要命。对，对。所以我问迈克尔·科门：“你是怎么把特雷西·莱茨请到剧组里的？”迈克尔·科门说他对特雷西的崇拜一点也不比我少。他说他是他的首选。所以他们就发出了邀请。然后他答应了。迈克尔说他当时真的是欣喜若狂。好吧，现在结尾要播出的那场戏对我来说就完全说得通了。嗯哼。我们待会儿会聊到。我们待会儿会聊到。因为迈克尔太崇拜他了。对，他对特雷西简直爱不释手。他说他们实际上拍了海量的有特雷西的素材，他真的很希望他们能继续把这个老掉牙的、
quote-unquote documentary. From 1971. In black and white. Exactly. But this was all just to show us, to give us a visual of, like, what this used to be and what it is now. Yes. Just the juxtaposition of this lively hustle and bustle, thriving newspaper. And now it's like in the same office space as a toilet paper.
所谓的“纪录片”穿插下去。1971年拍的。黑白的。没。但这一切都只是为了向我们展示，给我们一个视觉上的呈现，展示这里曾经是什么样，现在又是什么样。对。仅仅是这种鲜活热闹、生机勃勃的繁荣报社之间的对照。而现在它居然和一家卫生纸，
and toilet seat cover company, and it's not even the major earner. Yeah. So we cut back to present day. We're going to meet our first character from the Truth Teller, and it's Mayer. She's a young woman. She's sitting at her desk. Ding, ding, ding. We have our first adorable coffee mug, sighting.
以及马桶座圈套公司共用同一个办公空间，而且它甚至都不是主要的创收大户。对。所以我们切回现代。我们要认识《实话实说报》的第一位角色，她叫梅尔。她是个年轻女性。正坐在她的办公桌前。叮，叮，叮。我们发现了第一个超级可爱的咖啡杯。
Oh, what is it? Everyone else has had a paper coffee cup, and Maher's coffee mug is adorable. It's banana-themed. It's a bunch of little bananas, and they're all wearing little black-rimmed glasses. What? I missed it. I just loved it. And you guys, I'm going to give you a little sprinkle of what's on everyone's desk as we go through. Mayer's desk is very simple. There's an article that she has had framed, probably that she wrote, we're guessing, and a personal photo and some hand sanitizer. Well, we are going to learn that her job is compositor. And here's what she does. She just goes to the AP. She pulls stories that are in their subscription price point. Clearly, they haven't sprung. for the best stories.
哦，是什么样子的？其他人用的都是纸质咖啡杯，而梅尔的咖啡杯可爱极了。它是香蕉主题的。上面有一串小香蕉，它们都戴着黑框小眼镜。什么？我错过了。我太喜欢了。而且伙计们，我要跟你们分享一点大家桌上都放了些什么。梅尔的办公桌非常简单。有一篇被她裱起来的文章，可能是她自己写的，我们猜的，还有一张个人照片和一些洗手液。好吧，我们接下来会知道她的工作是排版员。她的工作内容是这样的：她登录美联社。挑选在他们订阅价格范围内的报道。显然，他们没舍得花大价钱，
No. And she just drags the articles into this, like, what would you call it? Yeah. Plops them in there, and then it formats them, and then voila. Yeah. Mare is played by actress Chelsea Fry. We got to meet her. We interviewed her.
去买最好的报道。没有。然后她直接把文章拖进这个——你管这叫什么来着？对。直接丢进去，然后它就会自动排版，然后大功告成。对。梅尔由演员切尔西·弗赖饰演。我们见到了她。我们采访了她。
If you didn't hear her interview, go back and listen to it because it's amazing. I was absolutely blown away by her performance. I'm a little obsessed. She's so good. She makes so many great choices. and you don't see her making them. Do you know what I mean? Yes. It feels so effortless.
如果你还没听过她的访谈，赶紧回去听听，因为太精彩了。她的表演彻底把我惊艳到了。我有点着迷了。她演得太棒了。她做出了那么多绝佳的处理，
Yes. I told Greg, I'm obsessed with her. Yeah. She's so good. Well, now coming up, you guys, we have the opening credits. Yes. I just loved them. I love the opening credits.
而且你看不到她表演的痕迹。你知道我的意思吗？是的。感觉太自然、太轻松了。是的。我告诉格雷格，我迷上她了。对。她太棒了。好吧，接下来，伙计们，就是片头字幕了。对。我太喜欢了。我超爱片头字幕。
We've seen the first four episodes, and I've watched the opening credits every time. Yeah. I'm not skipping the opening credits. They're great. What they are, you guys, is sort of a montage of vintage scenes of people using newspaper for anything other than reading it. Yes. Then you do see some people reading it. But we end on a shot of the newspaper and it has been used to line a bird cage. It's the character Nicole's bird cage and she is, and I guess the bird has peed and pooped on it because it's the liner of her bird cage and she
我们已经看了前四集，每次我都会看片头字幕。对。我不会跳过片头字幕。太棒了。伙计们，所谓的片头，其实是一组复古画面的蒙太奇，展示人们用报纸来做除阅读以外的各种用途。对，当然你也能看到一些人在看报纸。但镜头最后定格在一份被用来垫鸟笼的报纸上。那是角色妮可的鸟笼，鸟儿在上面撒了尿拉了屎，因为它是鸟笼的垫纸，而她正在，
is scraping it into the trash. Well, I love all of the images from this, but I also absolutely loved the theme song. It's very reminiscent of one we've grown to love. I think we should hear it. I'm going to be the I'm going to be. I'm going to I'm going to I'm Lady, I hope that one day this cast is walking across a stage, getting an award to that song.
把它刮进垃圾桶里。好吧，我喜欢这里的所有画面，但我也极其喜欢这个主题曲。它非常让人想起我们过去喜爱的那首歌。我觉得我们应该听听看。我要成为那个，我要成为那个。我要，我要。天哪，我希望有一天这个剧组能走上舞台，伴随着这首歌去领奖。
I know. I really do. I just hope they get it all. Can you please tell us about this song? Because it's just so special. It gave me like the chills, like when I hear the office one. And then, of course, I love the little callback to the very end piano keys. Well, Greg said that he did the same thing he'd done for the office in Parks and Rec in that he took submissions from a variety of composers. He asked a number of people, write me a song. And ultimately, he loved this one. It's by Nick Thorne Burn and Patrick Ford, but get this lady, after he picked the composition, he went to Bob Field and the Scrantones to record it live. They were the band from Booz Cruise, and they were also the musicians who played our theme song. That is so amazing. That is so full circle, and I feel like
我知道。我是真心这么希望。我只希望他们能包揽所有奖项。你能跟我们讲讲这首歌吗？因为它真的太特别了。它让我起了一身鸡皮疙瘩，就像我听到《办公室》主题曲时一样。而且，当然，我也很喜欢最后致敬钢琴键的那个小彩蛋。好吧，格雷格说他这次的做法和当年制作《办公室》以及《公园与游憩》时一样，他向多位作曲家征集了作品。他邀请了许多人：“给我写首歌吧。”最终，他一眼相中了这首歌。由尼克·索恩伯恩和帕特里克·福特创作，但你们听好了，天哪，在他选定这首曲子后，他找到了鲍勃·菲尔德和“斯克兰顿人乐队”来进行现场录音。他们就是《游轮派对》里的那支乐队，也是给我们弹奏主题曲的音乐人。太神奇了。这真的是一个完美的闭环，我觉得，
that's why it has a similar feel. Yes. Yeah. Love that. Okay, so the episode is going to start with a talking head from mayor, she's going to tell us about their one resident reporter, the Real Deal reporter. His name is Barry. When they need accurate local sports coverage, that's who they go to. They cut over to Barry. He is asleep. Yes. Yes. He's an older gentleman who's been there a long time. He is played by Dwayne Shepard, Senior, and he's our one reporter. That's it. Well, now we are going to meet. Oh, my gosh. She's my fave. Talk about owning a scene. Ah, we're going to meet Esmeralda, played by Sabrina and Pachitori.
这就是为什么它有那种熟悉的感觉。对。对。太喜欢了。好了，这一集要从梅尔的一个单人访谈开始，她要给我们介绍他们唯一的常驻记者，也就是真正的硬核记者。他叫巴里。当他们需要准确的本地体育报道时，找的就是他。镜头切到巴里。他在睡觉。对。对。他是一位在那儿待了很久的老先生。由老德韦恩·谢泼德饰演，他就是我们唯一的记者。就这些。好吧，接下来我们要见一位。哦，天哪。她是我的最爱。说到hold住全场。啊，我们要见埃斯梅拉达，由萨布丽娜·因帕奇托里饰演。
You might remember her from season two of White Lotus. She plays the woman at the front desk who's like running the hotel. Yes, she is incredible. And I just literally everything she says, I love her. I know. I have this whole thing where I go between Chelsea and Sabrina, and I'm obsessed with these two women on this show. Also, the moment we first met her, I felt like I was in a movie meeting someone. You mean when we met her in real life?
你可能还记得她在《白莲花》第二季里的表现。她饰演那个在前台负责管理酒店的女人。对，她太不可思议了。我真的是她说的每一句话我都爱。我知道。我一直在切尔西和萨布丽娜之间反复横跳，我对这部剧里的这两位女性简直着迷。还有，我们第一次见到她的那一刻，我感觉自己像在电影里偶遇什么大人物一样。你是说我们在现实生活中见到她的时候？
In real life. Yes. Because she came in in this beautiful outfit, but she had just come from hair and makeup. Yeah. And so she had all these curlers in her hair. She did, which is so funny because when she does her talking ahead in the episode, she's got clips in her hair. Yeah.
在现实生活中。对。因为她穿着一身美丽的衣服走进来，但她刚做完发型和妆容。对。所以她头发上还夹着一堆卷发器。对，真的太搞笑了，因为她在剧里做单人访谈的时候，头发上也夹着夹子。对。
So she's going to explain that she is in charge of TTT Online. I thought, when I first heard this, I thought she said titty online. Well, she does say that it's much more important, much more fun, and much sexier than the printed version of the newspaper. Because the print version is for people who just want to frame it if they're mentioned. But the online version, they can go on and on and on. There's no space issues. So she's going to show us one of her recent articles. It's called You Won't Believe How Much Ben Affleck tipped his life.
所以她要解释说她负责TTT在线网站。我当时想，我刚听到这句时，我还以为她说的是“大胸（titty）在线”。好吧，她确实说过，网络版比纸质版报纸重要得多、好玩得多，也性感得多。因为纸质版是给那些如果自己被提及了就想拿去裱起来的人准备的。但网络版，他们可以没完没了地写下去。根本没有版面限制。所以她要给我们展示她最近的一篇文章。标题是《你绝对想不到本·阿弗莱克给他的加长轿车司机给了多少小费》。
limo driver. And her description of it is so funny. I think we need to hear it. There's so many pop-up ads. Yes. At TTT Online, we have no space or length limitations. This is classic long-form journalism. Here is one of my articles I'm particularly proud of.
她对这篇文章的描述太搞笑了。我觉得我们得听听看。里面有好多弹窗广告。对。在TTT在线，我们没有任何空间或篇幅限制。这就是经典的长篇深度新闻。这里有我特别引以为豪的一篇文章。
I don't know if you can see it. So you start reading it. Yes. And you get very curious. I'm scrolling. You go next. Oops. I hit an ad and I click here. And I'm scrolling. And I'm learning a lot about the history of tipping. Like the first tip. What was that? Maybe a piece of cheese. And then you keep learning about colors of cars. There are so many colors. But it's not a waste of time. Because when you get it. to the end and you find out that the tips was $300? I mean, that's a lot. Lady, her article, it a little bit reminds me of me and you breaking something down, right? Like, because we're going to take you on a deep dive of the history of tipping and the types of limos that existed in the world just to eventually tell you that Ben Affleck tipped $300. Yeah. Every time we've watched this a few times now, and every time she gets to the part where she was like, what was the first
我不知道你们能不能看清。所以你开始阅读。对。然后你就会变得非常好奇。我往下滚动。你点下一页。糟糕。我点到一个广告，然后我点这里。我继续滚动。然后我了解到了很多关于小费历史的知识。比如第一笔小费。那是什么时候？也许是一块奶酪。然后你继续了解汽车的颜色。有这么多的颜色。但这可不是在浪费时间。因为当你读到，
tip? Maybe a piece of cheese. Makes me laugh every time. Every time. Well, while this talking head is going on, we get a real glimpse into Sabrina's office. It might be one of the most amazingly chaotic, crazy, vivid offices. Definitely on the set of the paper. There are so many great details. I'm going to list a few things I saw. First of all, there is a giant conch shell, then a left leopard printed swivel desk chair is what she sits on. There are gold little stars, like cut out, like construction paper looking gold stars. She's covered so many things in her office with gold stars. Multiple frames of just her covered with these little stars. Her laptop has stars on them, but lady, I thought of you. What? Did you clock how many lamps she has? No. She has a little tiny lamp
最后你发现小费竟然是300美元？我的天，那可真不少。天哪，她的文章，有点让我想起我和你一起剖析某种东西的时候，对吧？比如，我们会带你深入探讨小费的历史，以及世界上曾存在过的加长轿车的类型，最后只是为了告诉你本·阿弗莱克给了300美元小费。对。每次——我们现在已经看了好几遍了，每次看到她说到“第一笔小费是什么？也许是一块奶酪”那部分时，我都笑得不行。每次都笑。好吧，在这个单人访谈进行的同时，我们得以一窥萨布丽娜办公室的全貌。这绝对是整部剧里最混乱、最疯狂、最生动活泼的办公室之一。绝对是在报社的片场里。里面有太多精彩的细节了。我列举几个我看到的。首先，里面有一个巨大的海螺壳，然后她坐的是一把豹纹旋转办公椅。还有金色的小星星，像是剪纸一样的那种金色纸星星。她用金色星星把办公室里的好多东西都装饰了一遍。好几个相框里都是她被这些小星星包围的照片。她的笔记本电脑上也贴满了星星，但是，天哪，我想到了你。什么？你有注意到她有多少盏灯吗？没有。她有一盏超小的台灯，
with tripod legs with the little white square top. She has two big gold-based lamps with white rounded tops. Then she's got another like ye oldie lamp with like the pink shade with the tassels. God, I love a lamp. She's like you. I love a lamp. You, Sabrina, and Steve Curl's character on Anchorman. She also has a makeup mirror with a little makeup caddy. I clocked some half-burnt sage. She's been saging in there. Stacks of papers, cups holding pins and scissors, a hairbrush, an open glass bottle of some type of soda, and some very sad-looking plants. Oh my gosh, she is me.
带三脚架支架，上面是个小白方罩。她还有两盏大号金色底座的台灯，配着白色圆形灯罩。然后她还有一盏老式台灯，带有带流苏的粉红色灯罩。天哪，我太爱灯了。她跟你一样。我也爱灯。你、萨布丽娜以及史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在《王牌播音员》里的角色。她还有一个带化妆盒的化妆镜。我甚至还注意到了一块烧了一半的鼠尾草。她一直在里面熏鼠尾草呢。一堆堆的文件、装着笔和剪刀的杯子、一把发刷、一瓶打开的某种苏打玻璃瓶饮料，还有一些看起来非常蔫儿的植物。哦天哪，她简直就是我。
Sad plants and lots of lamps. That could be my autobiography. There it is. Done. I'm buying that book. It writes itself. Well, obviously, this is the pilot episode. So we're learning about all these people.
蔫儿了吧唧的植物和数不清的灯。这简直就是我的自传。就是这样。搞定。我要买那本书。这本书自己就能写出来。好吧，很显然，这是试播集。所以我们在慢慢认识所有人。
We've learned about Esmeralda. And now we're going to learn a little more about mayor. who says that before she worked here, she was in the Army. And she did write for the military newspaper, Stars, and Stripes. We got that paper when I lived overseas. Oh, yeah? Yeah, that's the paper I remember my dad reading growing up. Well, Esmeralda's going to walk around the office and introduce us to people.
我们已经认识了埃斯梅拉达。现在我们要多了解一点梅尔，她说在来这里工作之前，她在军队待过。她还为军队的报纸《星条旗报》写过稿。我住海外的时候我们家就订那份报纸。哦，是吗？对，那是我记忆中我爸从小看到大的报纸。好吧，接下来埃斯梅拉达要在办公室里转转，带大家认识更多人。
She's going to start with Nicole. Yeah, poor Nicole does not want to be on camera. And Esmeralda is going to make sure of it. She kind of like squeezes her face. And then it cuts to Nicole, we have a new Talking Head location. It's like a storage room. Yes, I loved it. I loved the visual of it.
她首先走向妮可。是的，可怜的妮可根本不想上镜头。埃斯梅拉达可不让她如愿。她差不多是捏住了妮可的脸。然后镜头切到妮可，我们发现了一个新的单人访谈（Talking Head）地点。就像个储藏室。是的，我很喜欢。我很喜欢它的视觉效果。
Behind her are all these old card catalog cabinets. You know, the tall ones that are made of wood and have the tiny little drawers. And then on either side of her are just shelves of files. Yes, and this is where we're going to get our like Talking Head Confessionals. Yes. You know what I thought? I thought of Leslie David Baker. Oh, and I thought of all the talking heads he sat in the background of.
她身后全都是那些旧卡片目录柜。你知道的，那种高高的、木制的、带有小抽屉的柜子。她两边则全是文件架。是的，这就是我们进行单人访谈忏悔的地方。是的。你知道我想到了谁吗？我想到了莱斯利·大卫·贝克。哦，我想到了他曾当背景板的那些单人访谈。
They made sure no one had to do that. Nobody had to do it this time. We're going to put you in like a closet for these talking heads. That's right. No one in the background. Poor Leslie and Creed, Leslie the most, but those two were in so many. I know. The only talking heads we don't see in this card catalog file closet are the ones in some people's offices that have actual offices.
他们确保了这次谁都不用那样。这次没人需要那么做。我们要把你们塞进像杂物间一样的地方来做这些单人访谈。没错。背景里没有任何人。可怜的莱斯利和克里德，莱斯利最惨，但他们俩出现在太多访谈里了。我知道。在这个卡片目录文件杂物间里，唯一看不到的单人访谈，就是那些在某些人办公室里（因为他们有真正的办公室）进行的访谈。
Yes, correct. Well, Nicole is going to explain that she's in circulation. So she keeps track of subscribers. She also just talks about how maybe they generate revenue by maybe collecting and selling information on people who accept all the cookies on their website. She has a very funny line where she says, you could say we get more information from the readers than they get from us. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Nicole is played by Ramona Young, and we got to interview her when we visited. It got cut short because they needed her back on set, but you can listen to that interview. Yeah. Her and I found out we were both on the Real O'Neils together.
是的，没错。嗯，妮可将解释说她在发行部。所以她负责跟踪订阅者。她还谈到他们可能是如何通过收集和出售那些在网站上接受所有Cookie的人的信息来创造收入的。她有一句非常搞笑的台词，她说，你可以说我们从读者那里获取的信息比他们从我们这里获取的要多。嗯嗯。嗯嗯。妮可由拉莫娜·杨饰演，我们去探班时采访过她。采访因他们需要她回片场而提前结束了，但你可以去听那次采访。是的。我和她发现我们都曾参演过《切尔西的罗尼秀》（The Real O'Neals）。
I know. You were on multiple things together, but you never really met. Never worked together. That's like me and Rob Lowe. We were on three projects together, and we never were in a scene together. Is there going to be a show? were me and you and Roblo and Ramona. Well, I think we need to make it.
我知道。你们一起参演过好几部作品，但你们从未真正见过面。从未合作过。这就好比我和罗伯·洛。我们一起参与过三个项目，但我们从未在同一个场景里出现过。会有这样一个节目吗？我和你，还有罗伯·洛和拉莫娜。嗯，我觉得我们得搞一个。
Yes. On mom detectives. Oh my gosh. Case number one. Exactly. All right. Now we are going to meet Detrick, played by Melvin Gregg. I'm so bummed.
没错。关于妈妈侦探。哦天哪。案件一号。没错。好了。现在我们要认识迪特里克，由梅尔文·格雷格饰演。我太沮丧了。
We didn't get to interview Melvin. I know. We got to meet him, but we didn't get to interview him. We got to chat with him on set. Then they started rolling. We had to whisk away. And then he was in scenes. Yes.
我们没能采访到梅尔文。我知道。我们见到他了，但没能采访他。我们在片场和他聊了聊。然后他们开始拍摄了。我们不得不被匆忙带走。接着他就开始拍戏了。是的。
He explains that he sells ads for the paper. And we also learn that he likes to cheer people up, specifically, Nicole. He's going to have a little crush on Nicole. Angela, we have seen Nicole's desk and Detrick's desk. Do you have a desk breakdown for us? I do. Okay. So Nicole's desk, now you're going to see this a little bit more later in the episode.
他解释说他是为报社卖广告的。我们还了解到他喜欢让人开心，尤其是妮可。他对妮可有点小迷恋。安吉拉，我们看过妮可的办公桌和迪特里克的办公桌了。你有什么办公桌大盘点要分享吗？有的。好吧。那么妮可的办公桌，你稍后在剧集中会看到更多。
Right now we've only seen a quick glimpse of it. She has a framed picture of her dog, some type of like, Stanley Cup, you know, like water bottle, some little twinkly lights that it looks like she's sort of strung around her partition. The thing I'm most curious about is the bird cage that's got the little, you know, cloth covering it because the bird is clearly inside. It's sleeping. It's sleeping. But yeah, she gets to bring her bird to work. And this made me think of a gal I worked with at 1-800 Dennis who would bring her parakeet dash to work. In a cage? Obviously. Right, not on her shoulder.
现在我们只惊鸿一瞥地看到了它。她桌上有张她狗狗的带框照片，某种像斯坦利杯那样的水瓶，还有一些她似乎挂在隔板周围的小彩灯。我最好奇的是那个鸟笼，上面盖着一块小布，因为鸟显然在里面。它在睡觉。它在睡觉。不过话说回来，她可以把鸟带到上班的地方。这让我想起我在1-800 Dennis工作时认识的一个女孩，她会把她的长尾小鹦鹉Dash带到公司。在一个笼子里？显而易见。对的，不是停在她肩膀上。
I don't know why I said in a cage. Actually, she had this little travel. I don't even know if I'd call it a cage container. It looked like a caboodle. Remember the makeup caboodles? Yeah. It was like plastic, but the top was kind of open and grated. And she could pop the lid open, and they let dash out.
我不知道我为什么说在一个笼子里。实际上，她有一个小小的旅行箱。我甚至不知道该不该叫它笼子容器。它看起来像个化商品盒（caboodle）。还记得化妆品盒吗？是的。它有点像塑料的，但顶部是那种开放式的网格状。她可以弹开盖子，让Dash出来。
It was okay. At 1,800 Dennis? At 1,800 Dennis. And he had a ball that he loved so much. It had a little bell inside it. And if you called 1-800 Dennis back in those days, you might have heard this in the background. And that was Dash kicking his ball. I had two parakeets growing up.
没问题。在1-800 Dennis？在1,800 Dennis。他有一个非常喜欢的球。里面有一个小铃铛。如果你在当年打过1-800 Dennis的电话，你可能在背景音里听到过这个声音。那就是Dash在踢他的球。我小时候养过两只长尾小鹦鹉。
Pretty was the name of the first parakeet. And Mango was the name of the second parakeet. And Mango used to fly around our house and would sit on my shoulder when I played piano. Yeah. Dash would hang out at Paula was the lady's name in her little desk cubicle. Or he would kick his ball. Down. All of our desks were connected. So you might have Dash just traveling down. Wow. Yeah. I want more bird is all I'm saying. Okay. I'm now intrigued. We've seen it in the opening credits. Now I see the cage on her desk. When will we meet this bird? When will we meet this bird? Okay. Melvin's desk, I will say, is a little bit more of a typical desk, you know, papers, post-it notes, things like that. Not too personalized. Not super personalized, but oh my goodness. Melvin, we need to discuss your computer screen.
第一只长尾小鹦鹉叫普莉蒂（Pretty）。第二只长尾小鹦鹉叫芒果（Mango）。芒果以前经常在我们家飞来飞去，当我弹钢琴时就会停在我的肩膀上。是的。Dash会待在宝拉——那个女人的名字——她的办公桌隔间里。或者他就会踢球。往下。我们所有的办公桌都是连在一起的。所以你可能会看到Dash一路溜达过来。哇。是的。我只想说，我想要更多的鸟。好吧。我现在很感兴趣。我们在片头里见过它。现在我看到了她桌上的鸟笼。我们什么时候能见到这只鸟？我们什么时候能见到这只鸟？好吧。我要说的是，梅尔文的办公桌是一张比较典型的办公桌，你知道的，有文件、便签之类的东西。个性化程度不高。不是超级个性化，但是天哪。梅尔文，我们得谈谈你的电脑屏幕。
He had so many tabs open. Seriously, he has like 10 tabs open. So he's got some digital clutter, lady. There is one other desk that I think really rivals Esmeralda's for the amount of things, and we'll get to it. All right. Well, speaking of Esmeralda, she's kind of flirting with the camera. I loved this so much, lady. This is my favorite moment of the episode. Her acting is so brilliant. Cassie and I were talking about it when I got here because this is her favorite moment. Oh my gosh. We've got to hear it. Let's hear it. You're going to get tired chasing my busy little buddy around with that camera. Also, I'm a single mom. So there's lots going on in my life. Anyway, here are two accountants and had accountant. Boring, boring, and head boring. God, not again.
他开的标签页太多了。说真的，他大概开了10个标签页。所以他有一些数字杂物，女士。还有一张办公桌，我觉得在杂物数量上真的能和埃斯梅拉达的不相上下，我们待会儿会说到。好吧。说到埃斯梅拉达，她有点在对镜头调情。我太喜欢这个了，女士。这是我整集中最喜欢的时刻。她的演技太出色了。我一到这儿卡西就跟我聊起这个，因为这是她最喜欢的时刻。哦天哪。我们得听听。我们听听看。追着我这个大忙人到处跑，你们那个摄像机会拍腻的。另外，我是个单亲妈妈。所以我生活里有很多事情要处理。总之，这里有两个会计和一个发型会计。无聊，无聊，还有个发型无聊。天哪，不会吧。
I'm not agreeing to any of this. Don't you guys have enough after nine years? Nobody wants this. You know what? You can't use my voice, my likeness, my face, nothing. Oh my gosh. This was so fun. This is the reveal of Oscar.
我不同意任何这些。九年了，你们还没拍够吗？没人想看这个。你知道吗？你们不能用我的声音，我的肖像，我的脸，什么都不行。哦天哪。这太有趣了。这就是奥斯卡的闪亮登场。
Yes, but the turn that she takes leading there. where she's like, flirty, flirty, and then she's like, I'm a single mom. I got a lot going on. Yeah. And then she kicks it over to accounting. And then, yes, we discover Oscar. Yeah, he runs away. He's like, you heard it. You cannot use my like, there's nothing. I'm not doing this again. And he runs in the bathroom and he slams the door. And then the next thing we see is a title card with a message on it that says, yes, we can. There's no end date to the release Oscar signed in 2005. Yes. He's now a reluctant participant in this ongoing documentary. He's got to be so pissed off.
是的，但她之前情绪的转变。就是那种，她先是抛媚眼，然后又说，我是个单亲妈妈。我有很多事要忙。是的。然后她把镜头甩给会计部门。接着，是的，我们发现了奥斯卡。是的，他逃跑了。他说，你们都听到了。你们不能用我的肖像，什么都不行。我才不干这事呢。然后他跑进卫生间，砰地关上了门。接下来我们看到的是一张写着信息的片头卡，上面写着：是的，我们可以。奥斯卡在2005年签署的发布授权没有终止日期。是的。他现在成了这部持续拍摄的纪录片中不情不愿的参与者。他肯定气坏了。
Well, we're going to see this play out. Like we said, we got to see the first four episodes of the show. And without giving too much away, it's kind of a soft launch because he's going to be avoiding the cameras. He's going to get drawn in. But I really loved that. I love that we got to see this familiar face. but he's not in the main storylines at first. He's going to get slowly drawn in.
好吧，我们将看到事情如何发展。正如我们所说，我们看到了该剧的前四集。在不剧透太多的情况下，这有点像是一次软发布，因为他会一直躲着摄像机。他会被吸引进来的。但我真的很喜欢这个。我很高兴我们能看到这个熟悉的面孔，但他一开始并不在主线剧情中。他会被慢慢吸引进来的。
I feel like we should mention the other members of this three-person boring accounting team because they're played by two more of the paper's writer performers, Bimasola Ikemelo and Alex Edelman. And they play Adelola and Adam, the other two accountants. We're going to see Barry now. Barry's desk area is sort of that classic. desk of someone who has worked at the same company for a long, long time. It has clutter, but it is clutter that has earned its place. For example, his desk is situated by a big column that's
我觉得我们应该提一下这个三人无聊会计团队的其他成员，因为他们由报社的另外两位编剧兼演员扮演——比马索拉·伊凯梅洛（Bimasola Ikemelo）和亚历克斯·埃德尔曼（Alex Edelman）。他们饰演阿德洛拉（Adelola）和亚当（Adam），另外两名会计。我们现在要见见巴里了。巴里的办公桌区域有点像那种经典办公桌，属于在同一家公司工作了很长时间的人。它很凌乱，但这种凌乱是它应得的。例如，他的办公桌位于一根大柱子旁，那根柱子是
part of the building, and he has covered that column with a whole bunch of little tiny newspaper clippings. Yes, probably articles he wrote over the years, I would think. We would hope. Well, Mayor is at her desk, and she's doing her business of pulling articles off the wire, and she just says, know what, I need some air. And we're going to now go outside and we're going to see someone approaching the building. But I think we should take a break. And when we come back, we'll tell you who it is. Yes, we're going to meet a young man with purpose. Mm-hmm. Summer's here and you can now get almost anything you need for your sunny days delivered with Uber Eats. What do we mean by almost? Well, you can't get a well-groom lawn delivered, but you can't
建筑的一部分，他在那根柱子上贴满了密密麻麻的小剪报。是的，我想可能是他多年来写的文章吧。我们希望如此。嗯，梅尔正在她的桌子前，她正忙着从电传打字机上扯下文章，她只是说，你知道吗，我需要透透气。我们现在要走到外面去，看到有人正在靠近大楼。但我觉得我们应该休息一下。等我们回来时，会告诉你他是谁。是的，我们要去见一个有目的的年轻年轻人。嗯哼。夏天到了，你现在可以通过Uber Eats配送获得阳光灿烂的日子所需的几乎所有东西。我们所说的“几乎”是什么意思？嗯，你不能配送一片修剪整齐的草坪，但你可以
get a chicken parmesan delivered. A cabana? That's a no. But a banana? That's a yes. A nice tan. Sorry. Nope. But a box fan? Happily yes. A day of sunshine? No. A box of fine wines? Yes. Uber Eats can definitely get you that. Get almost, almost anything delivered with Uber Eats. Order now. Alcohol and select markets. Product availability may vary by Regency app for details. With Amex Platinum, $400 in annual credits for travel and dining means you not only satisfy your travel bug, but your taste Two. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Conditions apply. All right. We are back and we are going to meet Ned Sampson. He's this nice looking young man. He's got a backpack on. He's played by Donald Gleason. Double crossover connection. He was in the miniseries The Patient with Steve Carell and the movie Fountain of Youth with John Krasinski. How about that? Well, we're going to learn, you know, he's super excited to be there.
配送一份鸡肉帕尔马干酪。一个海滩小屋？那可不行。但一根香蕉？那没问题。一个美妙的日光浴。抱歉。不行。但一个箱式风扇？非常乐意。一天的阳光？不行。一箱好酒？可以。Uber Eats绝对能给你弄到。用Uber Eats配送几乎、几乎任何东西。立即订购。酒精饮品仅限部分市场。产品可用性可能因Regency应用程序而异，详情请参阅应用。通过运通白金卡，每年400美元的旅游和餐饮额度意味着你不仅能满足你的旅游瘾，还能满足你的食欲。这就是运通强大的后盾。受条款及细则约束。好了。我们回来了，我们要去见内德·桑普森。他是个长相清爽的年轻小伙。他背着个背包。他由多姆纳尔·格里森（Donald Gleason）饰演。双重交叉客串连接。他曾出演史蒂夫·卡瑞尔主演的迷你剧《局外人》（The Patient），以及约翰·卡拉辛斯基主演的电影《青春之泉》（Fountain of Youth）。怎么样？好吧，我们要了解到，你知道的，他非常兴奋能来到这里。
It's his first day working at The Truth Teller. And he shares growing up, he didn't idolize Superman. He worshipped Clark Kent, who was saving the world by working at a newspaper. Yes, he's very idealistic. Yes. And as he's talking, he kind of runs into mayor who kind of runs in. Yeah, he knocks her whole salad. She's carrying this big salad, and he backs into her.
这是他在《真相报》（The Truth Teller）工作的第一天。他分享说，他在成长过程中并没有把超人当作偶像。他崇拜的是克拉克·肯特，他通过在报社工作来拯救世界。是的，他非常理想主义。是的。正当他说话时，他撞上了正好跑过来的梅尔。是的，他撞翻了她的整盘沙拉。她端着一大盘沙拉，他撞了上去。
unknowingly, with his enormous backpack, knocking her salad out of her hands, dumping it all over the ground. He never even sees her. All I could think about was Hugh Grant in this moment. Why? He hates backpacks. He does? Oh, my gosh.
在不知情的情况下，他用巨大的双肩包把她的沙拉从手里撞飞，散落了一地。他甚至都没看到她。我那一刻满脑子想的都是休·格兰特。为什么？他讨厌双肩包。他讨厌？哦，天哪。
Have you not heard him go off? No. I, okay, wait, this is so funny because I know what you're talking about. Yes, both him and also Kate Blanchette, have you seen these compilations of them? going on and on about the things that they hate. She hates leaf blowers. She does. Like so much, she hates them.
难道你没听过他大发雷霆吗？没有。我，好吧，等一下，这太搞笑了，因为我知道你在说什。是的，不仅是他，还有凯特·布兰切特，你看过这些视频合集吗？他们滔滔不绝地数落着他们讨厌的东西。她讨厌吹叶机。她真的讨厌。非常讨厌，她讨厌死它们了。
I think you need to hear his hatred of backpacks, though. Here's a clip of him talking about it on Late Night with Seth Myers. You are a man who you said, I believe, you are a walking pet peeve, in that you have a lot of pet peeves about human behavior. Yeah, I'm an angry little man. Yeah. Can I read off some of your pet peeves and have you tee up? You don't like people walking slowly.
不过我想你需要听听他对双肩包的痛恨。这是他在《赛·梅尔斯深夜秀》（Late Night with Seth Myers）上谈到这个话题的片段。你是一个这样的人，正如你所说，我相信，你是一个行走的宠物怨恨集锦，也就是说你对人类行为有很多看不惯的地方。对，我是个愤怒的小老头。是的。我可以宣读一些你看不惯的地方，然后让你来聊聊吗？你不喜欢人们走路慢。
I'm bearable. Backpacks. You don't care for backpacks. Why don't? What's all that? Why has everyone got a backpack? Take it off. Take it off. But what if they have their stuff in it? I don't care. Carry it in here. Okay. Oh, it's that it's a bag's not an issue. It's that it's on your back. Well, I use the subway, the tube in London quite a lot because you can't get around any other way. And there's always someone's huge backpack in my face with their stupid water bottle.
我简直受不了。双肩包。你不喜欢双肩包。为什么不呢？这到底是怎么回事？为什么每个人都要背个双肩包？把它脱掉。把它脱掉。但如果他们把东西都装在里面呢？我不管。拿在手上。好吧。哦，问题不在于它是个包，而在于它背在你的背上。嗯，我在伦敦经常坐地铁，因为你没别的办法出行。总是会有人的巨大双肩包贴在我的脸上，上面还挂着他们愚蠢的水瓶。
So you also don't care for water bottles? Why does everyone need a water bottle? So basically, I think Hugh Grant would really hate Ned's backpack. Oh, for sure. It took out a whole salad. And he doesn't even notice. I know. All right, well, he's going to go upstairs to these offices, and he walks in, and no one is expecting him.
所以你也不喜欢水瓶？为什么每个人都需要一个水瓶？所以基本上，我觉得休·格兰特一定会非常讨厌内德的双肩包。哦，肯定的。它毁了一整盘沙拉。而他甚至都没注意到。我知道。好吧，他要上楼去那些办公室，他走了进去，根本没有人料到他会来。
He's just a guy with a backpack who's walked in. He goes into the copy room. He's kind of wandering around. He's filming and taking pictures. He's so excited. He looks like a tourist. He looks out of place for sure. So Nicole clocks him, and she goes over, and she locks him inside of this copy room, which is a glass room.
他只是个背着双肩包走进来的普通人。他走进了复印室。他到处闲逛。他在拍视频和照片。他太兴奋了。他看起来像个游客。他看起来确实格格不入。于是妮可注意到了他，她走了过去，把他锁在这个复印室里，这是一个玻璃房间。
Yeah. And now employees start wandering over, and then Ned is going to discover that he's been locked in the room. And this whole exchange, it made me laugh very hard. I think we need to hear it. We do not have door money. This is just a misunderstanding, okay? I just start work at the paper. paper news or toilet news why would i say the paper about toilet paper we don't know you sir how should we
是的。现在员工们开始溜达过来，然后内德将发现自己被锁在了房间里。这段对话让我笑得前仰后合。我觉得我们得听听。我们没有门费。这只是一场误会，好吧？我刚开始在报社工作。报纸新闻还是厕所新闻？我为什么会把报纸说成厕所纸？我们不认识你，先生，我们怎么知道
know why you say the things you say i've got a meeting at two o'clock all right i'm just early that's all this is okay who's a meeting with just briefly i'm forgetting the name it's um no no wait wait wait wait wait Wait, wait, it's something unique. Is there a fantine that works here? You'll fight her in Limins. All right. I really love Detrick in that scene. Yes.
你为什么会说出那种话？我两点钟有个会，好吧？我只是来早了，事情就是这样，好吗？你是和谁开会？简单说一下，我忘了名字了，是……不，不，等等，等等，等等。等等，是个很独特的词。这里有个叫范蒂恩（Fantine）的人吗？你会在利敏斯（Limins）找到她。好吧。我真的好喜欢那一幕里的迪特里克。是的。
We don't know why you say the things you say, sir. Yeah. Well, Ned finally remembers Esmeralda's name. At the same time that Mayor finally returns and says, oh my gosh, I saw this guy downstairs. He was talking to the camera crew. He's legit. Yes. They let him out.
我们不知道你为什么会说出那样的话，先生。好吧。嗯，内德终于想起了埃斯梅拉达的名字。与此同时，梅尔终于回来了，并说道：“哦天哪，我刚才在楼下看到这家伙了。他在和摄像组说话。他是正经员工。”是的。他们放他出来了。
I want to point out at 14 minutes and 49 seconds, we see behind Ned in the copy room on the side of a filing cabinet the same yellow froggy 101 radio sticker that was on the set of the office. Oh, my gosh. Yes, little Easter egg. Well, I spotted an Easter egg on Oscar's desk that we're going to talk about later. Yes, and I have a clip. Oh, well, it's making me wonder if there are more of these. Like, if I watch it again, will I see more of them in the background?
我想指出的是，在14分49秒时，我们看到复印室里内德身后的文件柜侧面，贴着一个黄色的青蛙101电台贴纸，那正是《办公室》（The Office）片场里的贴纸。哦，天哪。是的，一个小彩蛋。嗯，我在奥斯卡的桌上发现了一个彩蛋，我们待会儿会聊到。是的，我有个剪辑。哦，这让我怀疑是不是还有更多这样的彩蛋？比如，如果我再看一遍，我能在背景里看到更多吗？
I think so. I think they're hidden all over. You think there's a Simpsons thing somewhere? I would think so. Right? I looked for it. Mm-hmm. If I missed it, let me know.
我想是的。我觉得它们到处都是，藏得很隐蔽。你觉得某个地方有《辛普森一家》的元素吗？我想是的。对吧？我找过了。嗯哼。如果我漏掉了，请告诉我。
Or a ducky? I don't know. I did see a stuffed animal on a filing cabinet. I couldn't really make out what it was. Mm-hmm. Okay, for future viewings. Mm-hmm. So when they let Ned out of the conference room,
或者一个小鸭子？我不知道。我确实在文件柜上看到一个毛绒玩具。我没太看清是什么。嗯哼。好吧，留着以后看的时候找。嗯哼。所以当他们把内德从会议室放出来时
everyone's going to kind of come up and introduce him, But my favorite is when Travis, the softy toilet paper guy, shakes his hand and then turns it into like a pat down. Yes. Just to make sure. I love the character of Travis. We have watched a few upcoming episodes. There are a few scenes that he's in that crack me up. Eric, you are hilarious.
每个人都走过来介绍他，但我最喜欢的是特拉维斯——那个“软绵绵卫生纸”男——跟他握手，然后顺势变成了一场搜身。是的。就是为了确保万无一失。我好喜欢特拉维斯这个角色。我们已经看了一些接下来的剧集。他出演的好几个场景都把我逗乐了。埃里克，你太搞笑了。
Yes, he's played by Eric Ray Hill, and he is our final writer performer. Oh, he is so funny. Yes. So Ned explains he's a new employee. Mayor is immediately worried that she's fired because she knows we don't have room for new employees. They get to chatting and he's like, I'm a little shaken up. I could use a bite to eat before my meeting. I owe you a salad.
是的，他由埃里克·雷·希尔饰演，他是我们最后一位编剧兼演员。哦，他太逗了。对。内德解释说他是新员工。梅尔立刻担心自己被解雇了，因为她知道我们没有多余的空间容纳新员工。他们聊了起来，他说：“我有点受打击。开会前我想吃点东西。我欠你一份沙拉。”
You want to get something to eat. She's like, sure. They now go down to a little cafe. It looks like it's maybe somewhere in the building, right? Like on the mezzanine level of the building. Yes. It's called eat hoose. Mm-hmm.
你想吃点东西。她说，行。他们现在下楼去了一个小咖啡馆。看起来好像在大楼里的某个地方，对吧？比如在大楼的中二楼。是的。它叫Eat Hoose。嗯。
Get it? Eat house. Mm-hmm. Yeah. And this is where the two of them start to get to know each other. It's such a lovely scene. I love Chelsea in this scene. Yeah.
听懂了吗？Eat house（谐音）。嗯。是的。在这里，他们两个开始互相了解。这是一个非常美好的场景。我在这场戏里超爱切尔西。对。
I love her. I have to imagine that when Greg was watching her in this scene, he was dazzled because she's incredible. She's so great, Nett. I did have questions. This is when I wish we had the script because Ned does this thing where he's picking out all of the tomatoes out of his salad. Yes, he's like talking about his backstory where he came from, but all the while, he's picking at his salad. Like separating things out of it.
我太爱她了。我忍不住想象，当格雷格看她演这场戏时，一定被惊艳到了，因为她太棒了。她太棒了，内德。我确实有问题。这时候我真希望我们有剧本，因为内德在做这件事：他把沙拉里的西红柿全挑出来。是的，他一边讲自己的背景、自己来自哪里，一边却一直在挑沙拉。就像把里面的东西一样一样分拣出来。
And she becomes very sort of fixated on that. She's like, what are you doing? And I was like, that had to have been in the script. Like, he didn't just do that, right? I don't think so because he has a very funny line where he says, oh, this is the pile of things I don't want to eat from the salad. This is the pile of eat alone's. And then this is the salad.
她变得对此非常关注。她说：“你在干什么？”我想，这绝对是写在剧本里的吧？他不可能只是即兴这么做，对吧？我不这么认为，因为他有一句非常搞笑的台词，他说：“哦，这是我不想从沙拉里吃的堆。这是可以独自食用的堆。然后这是沙拉。”
That's right. That's right. I just loved that writing. But what I do wonder is, is there someone. in the writer's room who does that to their salad. I'm sure. You know all these things make their way in. That's right. So we find out that Ned started by working at his father's cardboard company, then through a connection that his dad had at Enervate, he ends up working at Softies in Chicago, and now, per his request, he's been moved to Toledo to work at the
没错。没错。我太喜欢这段台词了。但我很好奇的是，编剧室里是不是真的有人对自己的沙拉也这样。肯定的。你知道这些生活细节都会融入进去。没错。所以我们发现，内德最早是在他父亲的纸板公司工作，后来通过他爸爸在恩内尔韦特（Enervate）的关系，最终去了芝加哥的“软绵绵（Softies）”工作，现在，应他的要求，他被调到了托莱多，在
newspaper. We also learned that he's a very good salesman. Yes. And we learn a little bit about his vision for what he wants to do here. We're now going to cut back to the offices where some people are talking. There's a hilarious conversation between Oscar and Travis, where Travis is sort of telling him how to behave if you ever hit a deer with your car, what to do with your car, to avoid hitting the deer. This scene was so funny, and this is a scene that I think might have gotten cut if you only had 21 minutes.
报社工作。我们还了解到他是个非常优秀的推销员。是的。我们还稍微了解了他对自己在这里想做的事情的愿景。现在镜头切回办公室，一些人在聊天。奥斯卡和特拉维斯之间有一段极其爆笑的对话，特拉维斯在教他，如果你的车撞到了鹿应该怎么做，怎么处理车子，才能避免撞到鹿。这个场景太搞笑了，我想如果你只有21分钟的时长，这个场景可能就会被剪掉了。
Yes. Because there's no purpose for this other than to just be very, very funny. to just watch two funny people in a funny scene. It does have a moment, though, that furthers the storyline that Oscar doesn't want to be in it because when Oscar sees the camera, he kind of scoches behind his computer monitor. Yes, that's true.
是的。因为除了纯粹搞笑之外，这个场景没有任何其他目的。就是看两个有趣的人在一个搞笑的场景里。不过它确实有一个推动剧情发展的小时刻——奥斯卡不想出镜，因为当奥斯卡看到摄像机时，他有点把身体缩到了电脑显示器后面。是的，确实如此。
So that does serve that purpose, but I couldn't help but think that Travis and Dwight would get along really well. Definitely based on this speech. Mm-hmm. And the pat down. And the pat down, you're right. I do want to give a quick shout out to Scott McGinnis, who is the prop master,
所以这确实起到了这个作用，但我忍不住想，特拉维斯和德怀特一定会非常合得来。绝对的，根据这段发言来看。嗯。还有搜身。还有搜身，你说得对。我想要在这里快速感谢一下道具师斯科特·麦吉尼斯，
for the paper. We chatted with him when we visited the set and we exchanged emails. He shared with us that he knew Phil Shea well, and he did a lot of the same things for the paper, like reaching out to local businesses for menus, magnets, et cetera, that Phil did for the office with the local Scranton businesses. And I asked Scott what it was like to work on the paper, and he said, is it possible to work with Greg Daniels without a story? He's wonderful. And I did ask him if we ever get to see that bird, he said yes. Oh, got some inside scoop. Yeah.
为这家报社做出的努力。我们去片场参观时和他聊过，还交换了电子邮件。他跟我们分享说，他跟菲尔·谢伊很熟，他也为这家报社做了很多菲尔当年为《办公室》里斯克兰顿当地商家做的事，比如联系当地企业获取菜单、冰箱贴等等。我问斯科特在报社工作是什么感觉，他说：“怎么可能不听格雷格·丹尼尔斯的安排呢？他太棒了。”我还问他我们以后能不能看到那只鸟，他说能。哦，拿到内幕消息了。对。
Well, now we're going to have a talking head by the character Adelola, and she's telling us about her deskmate, Adam. He has four kids. His wife makes him the same lunch every day. He basically eats whatever the kids don't want to eat. And I guess you could say I'm not sure she thinks very highly of him. While she's saying all of this, it's so hilarious to me because they cut to Adam. He is drinking out of a dinosaur sippy cup.
好了，现在由阿德洛拉这个角色做一个画外独白，她跟我们讲了讲她的同桌亚当。他有四个孩子。他老婆每天给他做一样的午餐。他基本上就是吃孩子们不愿吃的东西。我想你可以说，她对他的评价可能不是很高。当她说着这一切时，我觉得太搞笑了，因为镜头切到了亚当。他正在用一个恐龙吸管杯喝水。
He's like literally eating a kid's lunch. It's really funny. We see a little bit of both of their desks in this montage, and I thought I'd share with you. First of all, at Alola's desk, she's got a lot on her desk. She's got a lot of papers, a lot of things. It's a little messy. But I think she's where people go to get little treats. Because on the front of her desk, she's got a lot of her desk, She has glass canisters of candy. Oh. Kind of reminded me of Pam's desk a little bit. Okay. Okay.
他简直就像是在吃儿童午餐。真的太搞笑了。在这个蒙太奇里，我们看到了他们两人的办公桌，我想和大家分享一下。首先是阿德洛拉的桌子，她桌上的东西可真不少。她有好多文件，好多杂物。有点乱。但我猜大家都是去她那里拿小零食的。因为在她的桌子正面，她放了好多玻璃糖罐。哦。有点让我想起帕姆的桌子了。好吧。好吧。
Adam's desk is the one I was talking about, like Esmeraldas, holy, moly. How many more things could you fit on this desk? It is wall-to-wall things. And when we visited the set, we actually talked to Alex while he was at his desk, and he described it a little bit for us. I have various books that are, you can only see the spines of. This is a book by Ken Kwapas, who directed the second episode. And it's facing in, so he can't see the spine, but it says, but what I really want to do is direct, which is what Ken gave me the book. This is a book about one of my mentors in my job before comedy.
亚当的桌子就是我刚才说的那张，天哪，我的天呐。你还能在这个桌子上塞多少东西啊？简直被各种东西塞得满满当当。当我们去片场参观时，我们真的和坐在桌旁的亚当聊了聊，他给我们稍微描述了一下。我有各种各样的书，你只能看到书脊。这是一本由肯·克瓦帕斯写的书，他执导了第二集。书是反着放的，所以看不到书脊，但上面写着：“但我真正想做的是导演”，这是肯送给我的书。这是一本关于我在喜剧界工作之前的导师之一的书。
A guy named Larry Lukino used to run the Red Sox. The book's called Masters of the Game. And so, yeah, and because my character is a dad, he's got a bunch of, like, he can't play at home. So I've got a bunch of toys, like these Velcro ball catchers, like, Rubik's cubes, like this fart gun. Yeah, it does different farts. I have a question. Yeah.
一个叫拉里·卢基诺的家伙，以前经营过红袜队。这本书叫《游戏的掌控者》。所以，是的，因为我的角色是个爸爸，他有很多……就像那些他在家不能玩的东西。所以我有很多玩具，比如这种魔术贴接球器、魔方，还有这个放屁枪。对，它能发出各种不同的放屁声。我有个问题。对。
I have a question about this container of a toothpick cleaners. Floss picks. Is that props or is that you? Oh, that's props. The stuff that's made, but I love all of the props. This is a mini bopit. I'm really good at mini bopet, but once, like, in an early episode at like a 6am call time, I was like doing the bopet.
关于这个牙缝清洁剂容器，我有疑问。牙线棒。这是道具还是你的？哦，这是道具。这些是做出来的，但我太喜欢所有的道具了。这是一个迷你Bop It游戏机。我很擅长玩迷你Bop It，但有一次，比如在早期某一集早上6点的通告时间，我一直在玩这个Bop It。
like in a bit of a trance state. And I looked up and everyone was like watching me. It was the wrong kind of attention. I have a question about this Boston Snow Globe. Is your character, does your character have a Boston backstory? My character, like me, does have a Boston backstory. I'm from, I'm a proud Brookline, Massachusetts. Not a Newtonian, like Novak and Krasinski.
就像进入了一种出神的状态。我一抬头，发现大家都在看着我。那是错误类型的关注。我有一个关于这个波士顿雪景球的问题。你的角色，你的角色有波士顿的背景故事吗？我的角色跟我一样，确实有波士顿的背景故事。我来自、我为布鲁克林感到骄傲，我是马萨诸塞州人。不是像诺瓦克和卡辛斯基那种纽顿人。
but it's a bit of a tribute to all of the Bostonians who have come through the show. And, yeah, my character is from Boston originally, although it's never come up. I see that you also have the magic eight ball on your desk, which was in Michael Scott's office. And a magic eight ball seems to find its way onto a desk in every iteration of the office. So, you know, that wasn't my choice, but when I noticed it, I kept hoping that no one would call me on it because I really wanted to keep it because I was such a big fan of the original show. And so I thought, oh, man, Oscar has his little nod to Michael Scott. I love that I get to have a little tonny nod to Michael Scott, too, but there are so many. Yes, I have a bevy of chapsticks.
但这算是一个对所有参演过这部剧的波士顿人的致敬。而且，是的，我的角色原本来自波士顿，尽管剧中从来没提过。我看到你的桌上还有一个魔法8球，那曾是迈克尔·斯科特的办公室里的东西。在《办公室》的每一个衍生版本里，魔法8球似乎总能找到自己的位子，摆在某张桌子上。所以，你知道，这并不是我的选择，但当我注意到它时，我一直希望没有人会指出来，因为我真的很想把它留下来，由于我是原版剧集的超级粉丝。所以我想，哦天哪，奥斯卡有他向迈克尔·斯科特致敬的小彩蛋。我很开心自己也能有一个向迈克尔·斯科特致敬的小彩蛋，不过彩蛋实在太多了。是的，我有一大堆润唇膏。
I have lots of chapsticks. And this is a ball signed by a bunch of. of the crew, which is a really nice, nice thing to have. And yeah, there are lots of little nods to the crew around the office, a lot of the employees of the month or the, yeah, a lot of the plaques. And, like, is a really fun set. Isn't that great? Yeah. He also went on to show us all the pictures that are, quote, unquote, all of his many kids. And they're just all of his friends, kids, like people that he holds dear to his heart. But his desk had so many toys. It had a marble racer, had all these things, but I loved hearing how there was a little bit of things from his life
我有很多润唇膏。这是一个上面签满了剧组人员名字的球，能拥有这个真的非常棒。而且，是的，办公室周围有很多向剧组致敬的小细节，比如很多“月度最佳员工”或者是那些奖牌。而且，真的是一个非常有趣的片场。是不是很棒？对。他接着给我们展示了所有那些被称为“他的众多孩子”的照片。其实全都是他朋友的孩子，也就是那些他放在心上的人。但他的桌子上有好多玩具。有弹珠赛车，有各种各样的东西，但我很高兴听到里面既有来自他生活中的点滴，
plus things that are props, plus nods to the office. And I also just love how they continue the tradition like we had on the office of having crew featured in all these little places on plaques and things. I love that too. Well, now we're going back to lunch, and now it's Marr's turn to open up. And they're going to kind of agree together that this paper sucks, but maybe they can make it better. Maybe it can be, a real paper. Yeah. But in order to do that, Ned is going to have to meet Esmeralda.
又有各种道具，还有对《办公室》的致敬。我也很喜欢他们如何延续传统——就像我们在《办公室》里做的那样，让幕后工作人员的照片和名字出现在奖牌和各种小地方。我也很喜欢这一点。好了，现在我们要回到午餐场景，轮到玛尔来开启话题了。他们一致同意这破报纸简直烂透了，但也许他们能把它改好。也许它能成为一份真正的报纸。对。但为了做到这一点，内德必须去见埃斯梅拉达。
And he's going to have to tell her that he is taking her job. Yeah, he's editor-in-chief now. She can still run the online part. But he's going to basically replace her. Yeah, he's in charge of the print paper now. And he makes this apology to her. He's like, I'm sorry, I hope me coming in here and changing things up won't be too disruptive. and she says, oh, don't be so self-defecating.
而且他必须告诉她，他要取代她的工作。对，他现在是主编了。她依然可以负责网络部分。但他基本上要取代她的位置。是的，他现在负责纸质报纸了。他向她道了歉。他说：“对不起，我希望我来这里改变现状不会带来太大干扰。”而她说：“哦，别这么自贬身价了。”
Yes. She just clearly has him in her bullseye, and now she is going to just start taking jabs at him in all the tiniest and big ways. Yeah, there's going to be some future storylines that play out that are just her really, like, undermining him, but she pretends like... She's in his corner.
是的。很明显，她已经把他当成了眼中钉，接下来她就要开始在各种大大小小的事情上对他冷嘲热讽了。对，未来的剧情里会有一些情节，完全是她在暗地里挖墙脚，但她却装作……她站在他这一边。
Oh, it's just lost in translation, maybe. Like, I... Oh, there's just. There's one coming up, actually. Yes. Well, I also want to say, I just love that she's holding her cell phone in the scene. It's just so true to character. This is totally a person who walks around with their cell phone in their hand all the time, and she does, and I love it.
哦，也许只是翻译上的误解吧。比如我……哦，有一个情节马上就要播出了。是的。不过我也想说，我太喜欢她在这场戏里一直拿着手机了。这太符合她的性格了。这就是那种整天手里拿着手机到处走的人，她确实如此，我太爱了。
We are now going to have our first conference room scene. Yes. It's just between Ned and Ken, who is the guy we met at the beginning, who works for Enervate and Esmeralda. And basically, Ned is saying, listen, I'm going to need a few things to make the kind of newspaper I want to make. I'm going to need a full staff, dedicated reporters on multiple beats. And Ken is like, whoopsies, I'm going to call 911 because our budget is having a coronary. And he says, you know what else? I am going to cancel the wire service.
接下来我们要迎来第一个会议室场景。是的。出场的是内德和肯，就是我们在开头见到的那个为恩内尔韦特工作的人，以及埃斯梅拉达。基本上，内德是在说：“听着，我要办我想办的那种报纸，需要一些条件。我需要一个完整的团队，需要专门的记者跑多个新闻条线。”而肯的反应则是：“哎呀，我要打911了，因为我们的预算要心肌梗塞了。”内德接着说：“你知道吗？我还要取消通讯社稿件服务。”
We are only going to print original articles from this point on. Esmeralda looks right at the camera like, who the F is this a-hole? I know. Now, meanwhile, during this conference room scene, we see everyone out in the bowl. pen getting an email on their computers. It's from Esmeralda. Well, she's been clicking away. As soon as he started telling her the wire was going away and how he was going to change things, she is busy on her phone during this meeting. And what she's been doing is writing a letter to the staff titled Welcome Ned Sampson. And we're going to see people reading it. And one by one, people kind of start
从今以后，我们只刊登原创文章。埃斯梅拉达直勾勾地盯着镜头，仿佛在说：“这混蛋到底是谁啊？”我懂的。与此同时，在这个会议室场景中，我们看到大办公室里的每个人都在电脑上收到了一封电子邮件。发件人是埃斯梅拉达。好吧，她一直在那儿狂点鼠标。就在内德开始告诉她通讯社服务要被取消、他将如何改变现状时，她在会议期间一直忙着用手机。而她一直在做的事，是一封写给全体员工的信，标题是《欢迎内德·桑普森》。我们将看到大家在阅读它。然后大家一个接一个地开始
like coming over and looking in the room. Yeah, one guy comes over to the conference room and is like, hey, I'm here for you, guy. You know, same thing happened to me. Here for it to show you my support. And he leaves. And everyone's kind of like, what was that about? And Ken goes, I didn't even think that guy worked here anymore. Everyone else starts to walk up to the conference room, and there are these glass windows,
来到会议室门口张望。是的，有个家伙走到会议室门口说：“嘿，哥们儿我支持你。你知道的，我也遇到过类似的事。我来这儿就是为了向你表示支持。”然后他走了。大家都有点懵：“刚才那是怎么回事？”肯则说：“我都不知道那家伙还在不在我们公司上班。”其他人也开始走向会议室，那里有玻璃窗，
and they're looking through it pretty harshly at Ned. They are not happy. Ken is oblivious, but you can tell as Marilda is delighted. Well, Ned is going to excuse himself, and Mayor is going to show him something on her phone. it is the email, and here's what it is. Esmeralda has sent an email to everyone explaining that Ned has not been Me Tooed. That's not why he came here, why he had to get a new job. It was not because he was Me Tooed.
他们透过玻璃极其严厉地看着内德。他们很不高兴。肯完全没察觉，但你能看出埃斯梅拉达高兴坏了。好吧，内德要离开一下，梅尔则在手机上给他看了一样东西。那是一封邮件，内容是这样的：埃斯梅拉达给所有人发了一封邮件，解释说内德可没有被“MeToo（遭性骚扰指控）”过。他来这儿不是因为这个，他不是因为被“MeToo”了才不得不找新工作的。
Yes. So he has this conversation with Esmeralda where he's like, why would you send an email telling people that I was not something, that I was not her explanation is so funny, she's being so manipulative. It's amazing. I think we should hear it. Hey, can we talk? Of course. No. No. No. Her. Did you send an email to everyone here? Saying that I was not me-toed. Yes, because I didn't want you to start off on the wrong foot. But I wasn't. Yes, in fact. That's why I said he was not me-toed.
是的。所以他和埃斯梅拉达有了一段对话，他说：“你为什么要发邮件告诉大家我没有怎么样、我没有被……？”她的解释太搞笑了，她表现得太有心计了。绝了。我觉得我们应该听听看。嘿，我们能聊聊吗？当然。不。不。不。她。你是不是给所有人发了邮件？说我没有被“MeToo”？对，因为我不想让你出师不利。但我本来就没有。对，事实上。这就是为什么我说他没有被“MeToo”。
I don't think. I was not. I've never been me-toed. I've also never embezzled or slapped a waitress. Oh, well, should I tell them? No, that's what I'm saying. You don't have to not a thing that isn't. You are preaching to the choir.
我不认为。我没有。我从来没有被“MeToo”过。我也从来没有挪用公款或者扇过女服务员耳光。哦，好吧，那我需要告诉他们吗？不，这就是我想说的。你不需要……没有的事就不用说。你这是在对牛弹琴。
These are simple people. To them, a man leaves his job, moves to a new town. They think, I wondered what was he's crime did he do it to a person an animal I hope he doesn't do it to me that's why I wrote a mass email to everyone so instead they would think wait a minute hold on maybe I should wait and see what if my gut instinct against him is not completely completely right okay this is bad as Marilda you know what I'm going to tell everyone that everything that I wrote in that email was
这些都是单纯的人。对他们来说，一个男人离开工作，搬到一个新城镇，他们会想：“我在想他犯了什么罪？他对人还是对动物做了什么？希望他别对我下手。”这就是为什么我给所有人写了一封群发邮件，这样他们就会想：“等一下，也许我应该等等看，万我对他的直觉并不完全正确呢？”好吧，这太糟了，埃斯梅拉达。你知道吗，我要告诉大家，我在那封邮件里写的一切都
completely incorrect okay thank you okay you're welcome you're welcome no wait wait wait I think that's worse why why I think I think it's better if it comes from me I agree yeah everybody's going to appreciate your remarks oh cool no not now not now everyone everyone everyone This scene is brilliant. She is just a masterclass in acting. And then her way she yells at everyone to listen up. It's so incredible. So good. Poor Ned is just deer in headlights. Yes. Well, he is, in fact, going to take the floor. He's going to stand up on one of the desks in the middle of the bullpen. You know, this is the photo we've all been seeing. They released a photo of this moment when they were promoting the show. So this scene gives us this really great wide shot of the offices. You can see Ned standing on top of the desk.
完全不正确。好吧，谢谢。好吧，不客气，不客气。不，等等，等等，等等。我觉得那样更糟。为什么？为什么？我觉得由我来说会更好。我同意，对。每个人都会欣赏你的这番话的。哦，酷。不，现在不行，现在不行。大家，大家，大家。这个场面太精彩了。她的演技简直就是教科书级别的。然后她大声喊所有人听她说话的那种方式。太不可思议了。太棒了。可怜的内德简直像呆若木鸡的鹿。是的。好吧，他实际上要走上台去了。他要站在大办公室中间的一张桌子上。你知道，这就是我们一直看到的这张照片。他们在宣传这部剧时发布了一张这个时刻的照片。所以这个场景给了我们一个非常棒的办公室全景镜头。你可以看到内德站在桌子顶上。
You can see the softy toilet paper side. You can see the truth teller side. And I have to give a shout out to the production designer, Susie Mancini, who also worked with Greg on Space Force and Adrian Garcia, who was the set decorator. Greg and Michael shared with us that in the same way that Greg visited like a small paper company when he was developing the office. He and Michael visited several small newspaper offices in Ohio when they were developing the paper. And he said that something they noticed was that these old offices, they have a lot of style because this was the big, like, Google-type company of their era. And the set of the paper is modeled after some of the things that they observed touring these historic newspaper offices.
你可以看到软绵绵卫生纸那一侧。你可以看到说真话者那一侧。我必须在这里向制作设计师苏西·曼奇尼致敬，她也曾与格雷格合作过《太空部队》（Space Force），还有布景师阿德里安·加西亚。格雷格和迈克尔跟我们分享说，就像格雷格在开发《办公室》时曾实地参观过一家小型报社一样，他和迈克尔在开发这家报社时，也参观了俄亥俄州的几家小型报社。他说他们注意到的一点是，这些老旧的办公室很有风格，因为这是那个时代的大型“谷歌式”公司。而报社的布景正是模仿了他们参观这些历史悠久的报社时观察到的一些特色。
They wanted to create a place that felt like it had history. And I think you can see that. You can see that with the big columns in the room. Those windows, to me, really sell it. The windows are sort of this half moon. They sort of arch up high and come around. Yes. And there's these other big windows that are like trimmed in hard wood.
他们想创造一个感觉有历史底蕴的地方。我想你能看得出来。从房间里的大柱子就能看出来。那些窗户，对我来说真的很加分。那些窗户有点像半月形。它们向上拱起并弯曲。是的。还有其他的大硬木边框的窗户。
Yes. There's also this divider that has like dark wood trim around it and all this iron work. It looks like it's from the 1920s. But they did an amazing job with this set. And this is, I think, the first time you get to really. see the scope of it. Mm-hmm. Well, we have a few background catches during this great big wide shot.
是的。还有一个带有深色木质边框和各种铁艺的隔断。看起来像是20世纪20年代的风格。但他们在这个布景上做到了极致。我想这是你第一次真正能够看到它的规模。嗯。好吧，在这个超大的全景镜头里，我们发现了一些背景彩蛋。
Lady, you texted me and said, Ange, what is that at 24 minutes and four seconds? Is it what I think it is? Yes, it's something on Oscar's desk. Alex mentioned it. Yes, he referred to it. Yes. Here's what it is, you guys. Check it out.
女士，你给我发短信说：“安吉，在24分4秒的时候那个是什么？是我想的那样吗？”是的，那是奥斯卡桌上的一个东西。亚历克斯提到过它。是的，他提到了。是的。大家看，这就是那个东西，快来看看。
Oscar has on his desk that scarecrow doll made out of like, like burlap and twine, that Michael Scott gave him in the Goodbye Michael episode. Do you remember the moment? Here, let's hear it. Oscar, Oscar, Oscar. Oscar, you are very smart and you have a gigantic education. And I think of you as my scarecrow because you gave me a brain. So that's why I made you this.
奥斯卡的桌上放着那个由麻布和麻绳做成的稻草人娃娃，那是迈克尔·斯科特在《再见迈克尔》那一集里送给他的。你还记得那一刻吗？来，我们听听看。奥斯卡，奥斯卡，奥斯卡。奥斯卡，你非常聪明，你有着极高的学历。我认为你是我的稻草人，因为你给了我一个大脑。所以我为你做了这个。
Thank you Michael It's beautiful It looks like It looks like it was made by a two-year-old monkey On a farm And he just He just accepted That I put all this work into it
谢谢你，迈克尔。太美了。它看起来像……它看起来像是农场里的一个两岁小孩做的。而且他……他居然接受了我在这上面倾注了这么多心血。
Oh, man, he is the lowest opinion of me, of anybody. Oh. No one fake laughs better than Steve Carell, by the way. Well, this is true. I mean, I am, like, laughing because it's like that laugh sounds so real, but that's all performance. Yes. But, yeah, that's what Oscar has on his desk. Oscar brought that all the way from Scranton, and then he put it on his desk.
哦，天哪，他对我的评价比任何人都要低。哦。顺便说一句，没有人能比史蒂夫·卡瑞尔假笑得更好了。好吧，确实如此。我的意思是，我笑是因为那笑声听起来太真实了，但那全都是表演。是的。不过，是的，这就是奥斯卡放在桌上的东西。奥斯卡一路把它从斯克兰顿带了过来，然后摆在了自己的桌上。
Maybe he liked Michael after all. Aw. Well, lady, I know you have another catch because I caught it, too. Mm-hmm. This is just what we're going to call fantastic shoe catch. And Adelola has on some sparkly, bedazzled, shimmering boots. They're like a hot pink. Yeah. They're amazing. Yeah, her legs are up on her desk. I spotted them as well. Well, now Ned is going to continue his pitch for what he wants to do at the paper. And here's what he says. He says, He says, quote, if you have ever wanted to be the first person to know what's going on in the place where you live, or if you want to make sure the people who are running your city are telling the truth and doing the things that they said they would do, or if you just root for the underdog and you want to give it to the loud mouths, you are more than welcome all of you to volunteer your time at this newspaper. Because he says, I can't hire you. Mm-hmm.
也许他其实挺喜欢迈克尔的嘛。噢。好吧，女士，我知道你还有一个彩蛋，因为我也发现了。嗯。这就是我们要称之为“绝妙的鞋子彩蛋”的地方。阿德洛拉穿着一双闪闪发光、亮晶晶、Bling Bling的靴子。它们是亮粉色的。是的。太棒了。是的，她的腿翘在桌子上。我也发现了。好了，现在内德要继续他关于想在报社做点什么的推介了。他是这么说的。他说，他说：“引述一下：如果你曾经想成为第一个知道你居住的地方发生了什么的人，或者如果你想确保管理你们城市的人说的是实话，并且在做他们说要做的事，或者如果你只是支持弱势群体，想给那些夸夸其谈的人一点颜色看看，我们非常欢迎在座各位在这个报社奉献你们的业余时间。”因为他说：“我雇不起你们。”嗯。
And he spots Marv across the room and he says, Marv, is that okay? Can people spend a little bit of their time? Yeah, top boss Marv has come in. Yeah. And Marv says, okay. And you can kind of see in the room some people are feeling inspired. Yeah. And then he ends his speech.
他在房间那头看到了玛尔，然后他说：“玛尔，这样可以吗？大家可以贡献一点时间吗？”是的，大老板玛尔已经进来了。是的。玛尔说：“可以。”你能在房间里看到一些人受到了启发。是的。然后他结束了他的演讲。
He wants to address the Me Too thing. The not Me Too email. Correct. He says, by the way, me didn't. me wouldn't me believe in respect in workplace me haven't and mare's like shaking him off she's like you're good you're good it's fine esmeralda is not happy yes she is ticked off she throws a fit and then we have this last parting shot of her it's downstairs in the main huge lobby of the big building by the elevator banks and she's in her coat leaving for the day and she says in
他想谈谈那个“MeToo”的事情。那封“没有MeToo”的邮件。没错。他说：“顺便说一句，我没有。我不会。我相信职场尊重。我没有……”而玛尔则把他推开，好像在说：“行了行了，没事了。”埃斯梅拉达很不高兴。是的，她被气炸了。她大发雷霆，然后我们看到了她离开的最后镜头——那是楼下大楼巨大的主大厅，在电梯旁，她穿着大衣准备下班离开，她说：
In America, there is a saying about accepting things you cannot change. Well, we do not have that saying in Italy. I loved that quote so much. Well, you know, one of the reasons she's pissed is because Ned kicks her out of her office. Oh, yeah. Was that necessary, Ned? You couldn't have just This is such a big open space. You can't find another area? Another nook to call your own? You're going to kick her out of the big office? She has so much stuff in there. It's going to take her a long time to move. Well, we're going to see in the next episode, she's trying to move her stuff into a smaller space, and it's not going well. It's not fitting. Well, Ned is sitting, he's on his laptop, and he is watching this black and white documentary from the only old in 171. And this is when
在美利坚，有一句关于接受无法改变的事实的俗语。好吧，我们在意大利可没有这种俗语。我太喜欢这句台词了。好吧，你知道她生气的原因之一是因为内德把她赶出了她的办公室。哦，对。有必要吗，内德？你就不能……这是一个这么大的开放空间。你找不到别的区域了吗？找个属于你自己的小角落？你要把她赶出大办公室？她里面有那么多东西呢。她得花好长时间才能搬完。好吧，我们在下一集会看到，她正试图把东西搬进一个更小的空间里，结果很不顺利。根本塞不下。好吧，内德正坐着，看着他的笔记本电脑，他在看这部仅存于171年的黑白纪录片。这个时候
we have our cameo alert. We're talking to the newspaper man played by Tracy Letts again. He's giving a tour of the printing press. And we see Michael Komen. who is playing sort of a newspaper printer man. Yeah, and they're clearly having this great conversation. I was happy for Michael. Me too. Made me so happy. I mean, listen, I would definitely want to write myself into a scene with Tracy Letts.
我们迎来了客串彩蛋。我们又看到了由特雷西·莱茨饰演的那个报社男。他在带人参观印刷机。我们看到了迈克尔·科门，他扮演的是某种报社印刷工。是的，他们显然聊得很开心。我为迈克尔感到高兴。我也是。太让我高兴了。我的意思是，听说我要把自己写进有特雷西·莱茨的场景里，我绝对愿意。
Are you kidding me? Yeah. And Ned's trying to guess where they're going, and then she opens the door and in front of them, and it's so huge, is an old printing press. Yeah, she says, this is the original printing press, the thing you're seeing in this documentary. Yeah. So Greg told me they filmed this scene at the Santa Anita Racetrack. They have a printing room at the Santa Anita racetrack.
你在开玩笑吗？是的。内德试图猜他们要去哪儿，然后她打开门，在他们面前的是一台巨大无比的老式印刷机。是的，她说：“这就是原始的印刷机，也就是你在纪录片里看到的那台东西。”是的。所以格雷格告诉我，他们是在圣安妮塔赛马场拍摄这场戏的。圣安妮塔赛马场有一个印刷车间。
and he said the bigger working machines that you see in the black and white documentary were actually filmed at a place called Southwest Offset Printing in Gardinia, California. But this whole thing was inspired by Greg and Michael touring the small newspaper offices. He said they went into the basement of one of the buildings and saw these newspaper presses that were left over from when you actually printed newspapers that way. Michael said that they learned that back in the olden days, when they built these buildings and these presses, that you actually had to embed the press into the foundation of the building and then build the building around it.
他说，你在黑白纪录片中看到的那些比较大的运转中的机器，实际上是在加利福尼亚州加迪纳市一个叫“西南胶印（Southwest Offset Printing）”的地方拍摄的。但整件事的灵感来自于格雷格和迈克尔参观小型报社的经历。他说他们走进其中一栋建筑的地下室，看到了这些印刷机，它们是以前真正用这种方式印报纸时留下的遗物。迈克尔说，他们了解到，在过去老式的时候，当人们建造这些建筑和印刷机时，你实际上必须把印刷机嵌入到建筑的地基里，然后才围绕着它建造建筑物。
He said this was because when they were operational, they caused so much friction that they would have, like, shook everything in the building. so that that's why they had to be like literally embedded in the ground. They are so big. I wanted to do a deep dive, but it would have been a whole episode on the origins of the printing press. The Library of Congress website has really some great information, but they have old pictures and drawings and schematics of these printing presses. Some of them themselves were multiple stories.
他说这是因为当它们运转时，会产生巨大的摩擦力，会把建筑里的所有东西都震动起来。所以这就是为什么它们必须字面意义上地嵌入地面。它们太大了。我很想做一次深度探究，但这得做成整整一集关于印刷机起源的节目。国会图书馆的网站上确实有一些很棒的信息，上面有这些印刷机的老照片、图纸和原理图。其中一些机器本身就是好几层楼那么高。
Oh, Greg says that the one they saw was like three stories deep. He said it was like he'd gone in. into like the bowels of a Navy ship, and there's all these metal ladders that were going to the different levels. Yes. He said they loved it so much they had to incorporate it into the show. I was so glad they did. And I love when Ned says, what happens if I press this button, it's a big red button.
哦，格雷格说他们看到的那台有三层楼那么深。他说感觉自己像是走进了海军军舰的船舱底部，那里有通往不同楼层的各种金属梯子。是的。他说他们太喜欢了，所以必须把它融入到节目中。我很高兴他们这样做了。我特别喜欢内德说：“如果我按下这个按钮会怎么样？”那是一个红色的巨型按钮。
And Maher's like, I wouldn't do that. And he presses it and nothing happens because this printing press is old and no longer works. And then we cut to the documentary footage. and the character John Stack is talking about what that red button does, and I think we should hear it. So that button down at the end of the machine, that's, well, it's a magic button. We push that button, and the machine starts to rumble the life, and all of those people, the 900 people in this building, all of the information they've gathered, the stories they've found, all of that gets fed into the machine, along with the paper, and this good night process happens.
而玛尔说：“我劝你别这么做。”然后他按下了按钮，什么都没发生，因为这台印刷机太老了，已经无法工作了。然后镜头切到纪录片画面，角色约翰·斯塔克在谈论那个红色按钮的作用，我觉得我们应该听听看。机器尽头的那个按钮，那是——好吧，那是个神奇的按钮。我们按下那个按钮，机器开始轰鸣着恢复生机，大楼里的所有人，那900个人，他们收集的所有信息，他们找到的故事，所有这些都连同纸张一起被喂进机器里，然后这个美好的过程就开始了。
It is a kind of alchemy, and what comes out at this end is the truth. It's a truth teller. That's what we do. And I don't mean to be blasphemous, but I worship at the altar of this machine. Yeah, and that's how this episode ends. It's really touching.
这是一种炼金术，而从这一端出来的就是真相。它是真相的讲述者。这就是我们所做的。我不是想亵渎神明，但我崇拜这台机器的圣坛。是的，这一集就是这样结束的。真的很感人。
It really is. We go to credits, and at the end there is a tag. Well, we love our tag. We love our tags. Oscar is standing at the copy machine. The camera crew finds him, and he's like not having it. He's like, you know what? I'm going to make this footage unusable.
确实如此。进入片尾字幕，字幕结束后还有一个彩蛋。好吧，我们爱我们的彩蛋。我们太爱我们的彩蛋了。奥斯卡正站在复印机旁。摄像团队找到了他，而他根本不理。他说：“你知道吗？我要把这段素材搞得无法使用。”
And he just begins to say the most off-colored things, and they're having to bleep him like crazy. They're not doing a good job of bleeping him. You understand everything he's saying, by the way. They did not have the same. same standards and practices we had. No. And that is ultimately how the pilot ends. I have to say a big thank you to Greg and Michael and the casting crew of the paper and the folks
然后他开始说一些极其大尺度的粗话，结果他们不得不疯狂地给他消音。他们消音工作做得可不怎么样。顺便说一句，他说的每句话你都能听懂。他们当时可没有我们那种相同的标准和规范。没有。而这正是试播集最终结束的方式。我必须对格雷格、迈克尔、《办公室》的演员及剧组，以及孔雀（Peacock）的各位
at Peacock for letting us visit and for talking to us about this great new show in the universe of the office. Yes. We just loved it so much. I am in. I can't wait to see what happens. Well done. Yay.
表达巨大的感谢，感谢他们让我们来参观，并跟我们聊了聊《办公室》宇宙里的这部伟大新剧。是的。我们太喜欢了。我入坑了。等不及想看接下来会发生什么了。干得漂亮。耶。
A applause to everyone. And also a big thank you to Bobby Ray. Schaefer, Oscar Nunez, and Stephen Sox for sending us those awesome audio clips. Oh, and we want to give a shout out to Stephen and Lori's podcast, if we knew then, which is the number one Down syndrome advocacy podcast. Yes, it's great. They have created a beautiful community for parents of children with Down syndrome. We'll share a link to it in our stories. Thanks so much for listening, and we hope you have a good one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
大家鼓掌。同时也要大大感谢鲍比·雷·谢弗、奥斯卡·努涅斯和斯蒂芬·索克斯给我们发来那些超棒的音频片段。哦，我们还要向斯蒂芬和洛瑞的播客《如果我们当时就知道》（If We Knew Then）致意，这是排名第一的唐氏综合症倡导播客。是的，太棒了。他们为唐氏综合症儿童的父母建立了一个美好的社区。我们会在快讯里分享它的链接。非常感谢大家的收听，希望你们过得愉快。感谢收听《办公室女士》。
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. I'm going to be able to be. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》是奥德赛（Audyssey）出品的节目，由珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制片人是艾因斯利·布比科。奥德赛的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。本期节目由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《鲁珀特树》。我将能够……本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。